Kayson in front of us and it's only on
planning the law I'm not property law or
commercial or anything else if we can't
Ron stick to this we can get through
right bang my metaphorical gavel and say
good evening everybody and welcome to
the virtual meeting of planning
committee be my name is Andy Crump and I
will be chairing the meeting denied
members you have been provided with the
kachoris etiquette for virtual meetings
in fronts of this meeting however I need
to reiterate the main points one please
ensure your device is fully charged
always charging to please mute
microphones when not speaking 3 please
indicate in the chat bar or with a hand
function if you wish to speak for one in
variety to adjust the committee please
ensure your microphone is switched on
and switch off immediately once you have
finished please enjoy your switched off
or two signs any other devices you have
that might interrupt the proceedings if
any member including the Chairman
encounters IT problems causing them to
drop out of the virtual meeting they
should use their best endeavors to
rejoin as quickly as possible should the
meet the man but be unable to rejoin the
meeting they will be deemed to have left
the meeting at that point and the
meeting will continue provided it we
might score it please note that the
meeting is being broadcast live and that
members of the public are able to view
the proceedings right present online
with me on the following members of the
planning committee and all will invite
them to introduce themselves on Android
Crump I can hear and see all the
proceedings tense the Mills
then counselor mills I can hear and see
all proceedings that's the field and I
can hear and see everything counselor
firming yes I can see and hear the full
proceedings
that's the Hansa Seraphin yes I can see
and hear all the proceedings Casa cattle
cattle cattle I can see in here the
proceedings against the rock - the rock
I can see and hear proceedings thank you
yeah we've got no apologies chairman
thank you right also present on line
with me our offices from Democratic
service is legal and planning public
speakers will be given a 30-second
warning during their speaking time once
they've finished speaking the committee
may wish to ask you questions so please
remaining at the meeting if there are no
questions you can leave the meeting and
continue to watch the proceedings of on
the live broadcast when we come to vote
please come planning committee members
ensure that they identify themselves and
speak into the microphone so that their
vote is understood clearly by both other
members of the committee and also those
watching a live broadcast members should
respond for against or abstain and again
if we can please stick to the
applications in front of us and also
make sure we will facing using our
planning look at the planning
applications in the planning law and not
digress or diverge into other areas of
commercial or property law edge law or
any other law it's not appropriate right
moving swiftly on a first item on the
agenda is apologies for absence thank
you second is disclosure of interest
members have you got any items to
disclose German yes it's to do with the
item number for application lodged an
objection so I shall have to leave the
meeting unless there are certain
circumstances where I can speak
unfortunately cancer hunter Seraphin
there aren't any didn't register speak
because there was some confusion however
I as part of the application read out
your objection okay and that will be
noted in the records that your objection
was noted sorry no cats the fielding
just emails in from various interested
parties which I'm still open-minded and
I'm not being prejudiced by them caster
Fleming yeah I received emails from both
residents in Temple Grafton and also in
Studley parish council so just declaring
that I've had those emails but I'm
retaining an open mind on all of them
thank you can still for me cats kettle
please what said yeah I think if we we
put a blanket notification that we've
all received those or mostly receive
those and everybody's coming into the
application with an open mind we were
happy with that thank you right we
started casting the rock I didn't pick
you up there sorry
I say same interest as everybody else
but also and I declare an interest in
that moral rochedo portfolio happening
i've spoken on policy including the
Gypsy and traveler plan at Council and
with other councillors including the
portfolio holder and ward members for
the applications before the committee at
this meeting those interactions did not
include specifics of the applications on
the agenda this evening which I
approached with an open mind thank you
for that very clear casa kettle you just
to say I have had a conversation with
the legal officer about the legal
illegal aspect of one of the
applications but again that was a point
of clarification yep
brilliant thank you very much no move on
to the first item on the agenda first
planning application on the agenda which
is application number 20 slash zero zero
five one six ful the arts tables main
road locks the CV 35 90s proposed
two-story extension to existing dwelling
and our presenter officer is Victoria
Thank You chef
good evening can I firstly check that
one can see and the presentation on the
screen so this proposal is seeking to
add a two-story extension to the old
stables in Loxley the application site
lies to the south of the gold cut road
and is identified by the black dot on
the map by way of reference this aerial
image shows the application site
outlined in red or the additional land
owned by the applicant is outlined in
blue the old stables is located here the
adjoining barn here Home Farm here and
there's additional outbuildings that lie
here
so the odd stables was historically an
outbuilding in association with home
farm and was converted into a dwelling
in the 90s as part of the initial
conversion the old stables had a
significant amount of rebuilding work
including the addition of a roof the
site lies within the failed important
special landscape area and two public
rights-of-way lie to the east in terms
of the proposed development the north
east elevation shows the proposed
extension to the left hand side the
extension would be at right angles to
the existing form of outbuildings and
would be finished in reclaimed brick the
eater of the extension would be nearly 1
metre higher than the ease height of the
old stables and you can see that the
extent would incorporate different
architectural details and include modern
and modern glass link which we think the
two buildings at first floor level are
shown here so the rear elevation of the
extension would have a similar
appearance to that of the front
elevation although there would be
alterations with the roof lights on the
main house so if I reason of the
extension citing the proposal would
partially obscure the original southern
wall of the barn I shown here new full
height folding doors would be installed
at ground floor level and there will be
a feature window at first floor level
which would be crowded in timber glass
sink mentioned previously is further
detailed on this on this slide and
there'll be glass here here here adhere
wall plan shown while the proposal would
create a utility room and dining family
area at ground floor a first floor level
the extension would provide a master
bedroom an ensuite
internal reconfiguration of the main
barn would provide an additional bedroom
turning the one bedroom dwelling into a
three bedroom house the initial
conversion was permitted as a two
bedroom property so the odd stables is
shown here in stone and brick building
is here joining conversion called the
barn
this photo illustrates how the
building's maintained a traditional
linear form the next photo gives you an
idea of the access to the old stables
and demonstrates the design features
observed on the northern elevation of
the north of the adjoining building this
photo shows are setting up the old
stables which is characterized by an
arrangement or further outbuildings
serving home farm now this next photo
shows the end gable of the old stables
and the surrounding garden area serving
that property the Stonewall wood will be
removed as part of the proposal shown
here this is a beautiful the property
from the closest public footpath given
the scale and design of the extension
the proposal is considered to be
unacceptable in principle which would
erode the historic character of the barn
conversion and in turn caused harm to
the character of the Feldon parked in
special Don scape area it is recommended
that this application should be refused
for the reason set out in the officer's
report thank you
shall you mute it Thank You Victoria no
updates on this one is that no if
there's no updates thank you right if we
could move on to our first speaker which
is counselor Glenn Jones from Locksley
Parish Council can you hear us counselor
Jones
good evening chair and committee members
on I'm hoping you can all hear me yes we
can hear you you will have three minutes
and we will give you a warning with 30
seconds to go I don't know when you
heard my spiel at the start once you've
finished your speech confident could you
please stay with us
as there might be questions the
committee what to ask you so please
don't don't run away and and if you
could far away when you're ready please
okay well I'll be fairly brief so I
won't need that the three minutes I just
want to make four points to the
committee which underpin our support for
the application I think first and most
significantly the bond itself is not a
list restructure and while its pleasant
it's of no particular architectural
merit and indeed if you were to be in
front of that you'd be hard pushed to
know that had previously been used as a
bar and given it its scale and also its
location within a cluster of residential
buildings in that sense the application
of the policy relating to preserving
traditional born scriptures to us seems
inappropriate because whilst it's old it
is can only be described as a
traditional boardbarn structure and it's
difficult you know to see it as that
second I mean I will leave that to mr.
Herold to describe in further detail but
in terms of the importance of the
extensions that his family but I can
confirm for many decades the family has
lived in the village and that support is
provided to a number of elderly family
members
to live in adjacent properties in the
context of Kovac 19 we would emphasize
the importance of this intergenerational
support which the proposed development
would continue to enable the third point
I think is one of context and of course
each planning application must be
considered on this individual net merits
however there has to be a degree of
consistency across the piece and in
light of recent decisions in Loxley if
if this application were refused it
would appear to be highly inconsistent
with recent decisions and decisions I'm
particularly thinking about the recent
approval to develop a relatively large
new house which lies within 200 yards of
this application and also sits with a
special landscape area it just appears
to be highly inconsistent the fourth
point is that we have and thanks to
their committee for recently approving
our neighborhood development plan and
this application does lie within the
built-up area boundary the NDP of course
just supports very strongly meeting
local housing needs in our view as a
parish council there is nothing in
design terms which appears to contravene
policies set out in the village design
statement or the NDP I say that as
somebody who actually drafted a village
design statement so I am very intimate
with its contents and in any case I
think the NDP is primarily focused on
the development of new homes not
extensions so those are the four key
reasons that we would put to you which
about just to reiterate those it's
actually you'd be hard pushed to know
it's estaban secondly intergenerational
equity third consistency in terms of
planning applications and fourth it does
lie within the Bo AB and actually as far
as we see it does not contravene
policies set out in the village design
statement ok thanks very much for your
time
Thank You mr. Jones councillor Jones
whichever you prefer the best yeah I
think councillor Jones is probably more
appropriate sorry about that okay any
question any questions for accounts the
Jones please can stand just heard a
faint then catch the rock please ah
hello there are there any objections for
a name from neighbours in the close
vicinity
that's all nor that I am aware and I had
pretty much 90 Potter 99.9% I'm sure
there will be no objections because of
actually its its relatives that live
adjacent to the properties and we've not
heard anything in fact most people would
be unaware that any development has
taken place there post development okay
thank you
to catch the rock place Thank You
chairman good evening alluded to the
recently made neighborhood development
plan the officers report suggests that
in her opinion is contrary to policy
anyone
you did say you're intimately familiar
with the the Negril development plan
you've obviously have a difference of
opinion there could you explain what
what how you view that difference please
I do understand
I was very interested to find out what
what the objection was in relation to
the village design statement so I
specifically asked the consultant
yesterday to forward me the relevant
element of the officers report and that
that sort of reference is is a very sort
of vague reference in that policy to
being in keeping with development in in
the village and you know I don't see
anything here in terms of either the
scale or the location or the visibility
which was concern us as a parish council
as a scale it's
relatively small-scale extension to an
existing property in terms of its
location whilst it is within the special
landscape area we're not talking about a
new development and in terms of
materials I think the NDP itself you
know is not averse to the use of modern
materials where appropriate and I think
this context is appropriate as I
mentioned previously this would be
totally inconsistent to refuse this then
within 200 yards approve a relatively
large new house within 200 yards of this
application which does lie within the
special landscape area and is a signal
much more significant intrusion into the
landscape than this property and and
this is the sort of thing that that
appears inconsistent and I think you
know would undermine public sort of
supports for planning more more widely
because the two decisions would just
feel in Congress so I hope that thank
you thank you all right any further
questions for the judge please thank you
counts to the dance you're free to go
but please stay with us and watch online
thank you thank you
right our next week did you indicate the
kettle had got the hand up one but
hadn't got the yep thank you so thank
you mr. chairman just going I've got you
haven't I have I've got a map of Loxley
and there's a vein called ma'am Elaine
with a property which at the end of man
Lane seemed I suppose it might just be
call the manor by chance
and there are two properties there is
that the new property to which are
referring no could you just identify
where the new property is if you can
describe in Ultron as a visual thing the
new property is actually on the approach
towards home farm and and the approach
towards development which we are
actually looking at so it is literally
within 200 yards I would guess of the
existing property so it's on the
approach to home from I can't name a
because I don't think it's actually got
all lane so I'm not sure it's actually
got a name but it's adjacent to Four
Winds
okay so if I I was in Lockland yesterday
if I turn up that drive towards Manor
Farm interment along there now if you
turn up the drive towards home farm home
farm sorry yes I'm at home sorry
yep what that's right where the
applicant lives you would just turn up
there and go up there again about 150
yards and it will be on your left and it
is a it is a property which is
approximately 220 to 30% larger than the
adjacent neighboring properties so it is
a it is a large development which is
what I'm saying about the issue with
consistency yeah we going where we going
on this questioning please I just wanted
to identify where the new property was
and I was just going to say it have been
any comments from the residents of
Marathon or the second property at Manor
Farm I think in the report council
kettle that there was no comment thank
you thank you the questions on all the
different type of medium of requesting
questions right it was a bit of false
start
you are free to go now counselor Jones
and we can
move on to our next speakers I think
it's a combination of two I've got this
right which is mark world-ish and
William Harold Morgan are you both here
gentlemen please yeah I'm here can you
say who you are please yes William
Morgan Harold thank you I'm Marcus I'm
the agent and apologies to mr. Morgan
Harold we've got you the other way round
so apologies for that yeah with Morrison
and I'll get caught all sorts of
different versions of it so I can fully
yet sympathize and again I apologize for
that sauce you've got three minutes
gentlemen between you how would you like
to play it i.e agent fox mccloud just
under two minutes hopefully and then
okay then dish if you fall away and then
move on to mr. afterwards please okay
right thank you
hi
the original conversion of this dwelling
was carried out approximately 30 years
ago and was not executed in a
particularly sympathetic manner and this
is evident in the use of modern stolen
casement windows modern bellick's roof
lights and the introduction of a chimney
all of which heavily domesticate the
appearance of the building and detract
from the agricultural heritage
unfortunately the case officer has just
read the words behind conversion and
defaulted to a rigid interpretation of
the SPD which is only a guidance
document and not policy and so officers
should apply a degree of common sense
and perspective to the context at a 100
square metres if this proportionately
large one-bedroom dwelling is suitable
for only a single person or a couple the
proposed 49 square metre extension would
result in the more discreet bedroom
family home that would allow my client
to remain living in their existing home
next door to the elderly parents within
a stone's throw the proposed extension a
350 square metre new dwelling has
recently been granted planning concerns
how can the case officer logically
justify or deny a small extension when
what will be one of the biggest houses
in the village has been approved next
door
the officers report highlights of the
proposed extension is not traditional in
its appearance this aspects of the
design was deliberate to mimic the
existing building would not not result
in a cohesive design and instead result
in a pastiche and the first extension
was making good use of traditional
materials and design cues is intended to
be clearly definable as a later edition
so the fabric of the contest
the original building remains and tasks
first and foremost this is my clients
home and the original barn was not a
listed building or of any significant
architectural merit or historical value
and the poorly executed conversion
thirty years ago did little to conserve
the agricultural heritage of the
building and it is therefore now
reminded to merely be hung up on the
word span conversion when denying this
proposed extension quite simply it
should be considered as a domestic
extension that are days to all the
extending your home criteria there will
have a negligible impact to the
neighbors and surroundings but makes a
significant difference to my clients
life and being able to continue living
in their home well into the future thank
you very much thank you mr. Morgan thank
you and so I ask that this planning
proposal be approved as the idea of my
wife and I relocating is deeply
upsetting if our home can't evolved and
we will need to relocate me and we'll be
tearing up a closed intergenerational
family have been together and part of
this community for 30 years we purchased
the old stables two and a half years ago
with the vision of starting a family of
our own turning a one-bedroom property
into a modest three-bedroom that would
allow our children to experience the
wonderful upbringing that our homes
location provides as a family with tight
social bonds having to relocate will
remove the support we offer to our
elderly relatives my mother-in-law
76 and widowed lives directly opposite
us my wife died on 79 lives alone in two
my wife's granddaddy was a hundred and
six lives in Wales born the recent
pandemic and lockdowns proved a support
vital we've done their shopping picked
up their pensions and political
prescriptions on a weekly basis but most
importantly were their social support
Brent well within time right any
questions for the agent or the applicant
please just like to comment on I'm very
impressed with a 160 year old
grandfather so our best wishes to him as
well so thank you very much
yeah like man yes every if we mentioned
that mentioned on the live live
broadcast though very impressed right
any any questions to let me go back into
the other sections who's requesting to
speak catch the cattle please first
thank you just in terms of the design it
could be something I could I could deal
with the planning officer but since
you're there I'm going to ask you first
it would appear that the stonework is
going to be reclaimed and that's what
the planning officer indicated but it
does appear from the pictures is going
to be a different style different colors
the existing brickwork on the original
barn conversion although I have heard
what you have to say about word barn
conversion so I'm just using that
terminology would you I don't know if
it's part of the application or whether
it's a subsequent condition but would
you look to having stonework or
brickwork that match the existing
buildings would be used in the extension
would be as close as possible match to
the brick at the other end of the
building which is the bond which is the
dwelling called the bond but the
brickwork would be you
carefully selected to be a matching as
best as it can be and that would
normally be something that would be
conditioned through the planning
approval if it is indeed granted yep I'm
good for that any further questions I'm
just again in through the different
medium no right and gentlemen thank you
very much more concise presentations and
concise answers next speaker which is
the ward member cancer O'Donnell can you
hear us yes thank you sure you've got
five minutes again we'll give you the
warning
I'll see you know therefore been on this
committee yeah look good well before so
far away when you're ready please Thank
You chair good evening committee um I
speak in support of this application
which meets a number of our core
strategy elements adheres to policies
within the newly adopted Loxley NDP is
within the be UAB and most importantly
is fully supported by the parish council
as we adjust to the new normal we are
only too aware of just how well our
parishes know and understand their
residents Locksley Parish Council has
been a leading light in organizing local
resident support and it it truly is a
tight-knit community parish councils
have been at the very core of community
support during this pandemic we are also
only too aware of the importance of
close family support and the need to
protect the vulnerable within our
society and the light has been shown on
how we look after and prepare for the
golden years of our older generations
what does it have to do with planning I
hear you ask
while future policies are being
discussed what applications will connect
health planning and social care and how
applications such as this support inter
generate which support intergenerational
living will be actively encouraged
you'll have seen that there is
consistent parish support this
application and the applicant and
architect have been in constant
communication with the parish council
and local residents I'm unsure how many
of you will have managed to do si prison
visit giving covert if a site visit has
not
be possible I would strongly recommend
that this is an occasion sensitive
application however if you have visited
rather than trusted Google Earth you
will not only have noticed and passed
the large executive home being
constructed on the way in to Penn Farm
estate but you will have also seen just
have contained home farm with its
surrounding buildings including the old
stables actually is and if noted how the
old stables is at the very end of the
driveway with and the extension would
not impact upon the view of the Feldon
parkland special landscape area granted
you would see the old stables as you
walk past to go to the special landscape
area but it could be argued that you
will be not be / - physically distracted
anymore than you are now on your walk I
questioned how this form a stable barn
could be deemed to have any particular
agricultural design or value and it
could be suggested and I know the
applicant will not take offence at this
remark that any alteration could only
really improve its outward appearance
supplication supports cs1 as it provides
an increased supply of housing to meet
needs of present and future generations
this meets the needs of the present
without compromising the ability of
future generations to meet their own
needs it is in keeping with zs5 as it
respects the local distinctiveness of
the surrounding area and through
respecting the natural environment it
also respects cs6 through the sensitive
design and its integration into the
existing build form it meets the
requirements of cs9 or distinctiveness
and design also of consideration is the
Loxley NDP and respecting what the
villagers overwhelmingly voted on as
their vision for Loxley a theme running
throughout the NDP is that the villagers
housing stock is now significantly
skewed towards larger homes in contrast
to the smaller size of most households
87% comprises of three plus bedroom
properties and three-bedroom homes such
as the one that our applicant is looking
for comprises only 25% of the stock the
household size is average of 2.5 6
persons per household and majority of
households comprised of two people per
household in stark contrast to the
number of two-bedroom properties
available which accounts just 8% of the
stock this mismatch prevents younger
families finding suitably sized
accommodations such as our applicants as
they look to start a family and need to
stand to three rather than a one-bed
property juice the imbalance between
larger houses and three bed and less
Loxley has a demographic structure that
is skewed to the older age groups with
sixty to seventy four-year-olds and far
fewer younger people between the zero to
thirty four year-olds relative to the
national average and Loxley needs
younger families such as the applicants
the NDP set goals which aim to and I
quote ensure sensitive development which
protects and enriches the landscape and
built setting this is critical to
ensuring that the development that has
required addresses wider community needs
provides for greater housing choice in
locations that minimize environmental
impact and delivers greater
intergenerational equity these are the
keys to delivering the community vision
and then when looking at the overall
look and feel of Loxley they stated
regarding design and character policy
age three this policy is not intended to
impose a particular architectural style
or stifle innovation originality or
innovative design through
unsubstantiated requirements to conform
to a certain development of forms or
styles and then when looking and I admit
this is - replacement dwellings but it
does give you a feel of how the village
view renewal of housing stock they felt
that this policy would be designed to
facilitate the renewal at the existing
housing stock with appropriate
replacements it is not intended to avert
restrict people's freedom of expression
of interest in design and layout
therefore committee by granting a modest
extension to the old staples you will be
enabling a family to stay within a
village they have lived in for 30 years
and have strong links with it will
ensure that the applicants Pantaloon
widowed mother and earthly relatives
will not need to relocate as their her
family are literally on hand and he loss
to assist in encouraging younger
families to stay within Locksley I would
therefore ask you to look favorably on
this application
thank you Donal have you got any
questions
no questions no no
no thank you cancer I dunno
you'd obviously answered all their
questions where your comprehensive
speech there so thank you for that well
now move on to points of clarification
the officer and kiss the fielding I
believe got a question the officer
could we take the white screen down and
show you one one please please please
please please thank you sorry I was only
dragged up I wasn't brought up um the
ones showing the design the elevation of
the house is this one correct this one
yes on the elevation there you've got on
the existing building it looks like
you've got lean-to or is it a shed
that's attached to the bond thank you
are you talking about this bit here what
were you indicating that the
single-story element in the in the
middle no no no at the end of it at the
end of the building of the existing barn
not the the not the attachment it's on
the existing image what is that sorry
about that
that's - that's a wall I can show you a
photo of it as part of the conversion it
is proposed that that will be demolished
so you can see it there that's just just
the wall there a wall okay yes I'll go
back to the elevation so your question
finished counts the building yeah now I
just wanted to know what he was thank
you catched the rock please
Thank You chairman one of the speakers
said that the extension was 49 square
metres and the original dwelling was a
hundred square meters I find a reference
to that in the report could you confirm
that ratio is about correct please yes
bear with me
so my calculations are very similar that
the existing house measures 100 square
meters and the proposed ground floor and
first floor measures 50 square meters
thank you very much right thank you
test the kettle please Thank You mr.
chairman yeah Victoria just a quick
question you said that the roofline was
higher than the existing building
looking at the claim that you helpfully
got in front of us already it would seem
that the roofline from the drawing as
opposed is actually below the roofline
of the main part of the barn to Eve's
right the ridge high trees below so the
rich height is below the main stables
here but I believe it's slightly higher
than the barn here okay under the SPD we
are in time to look at the inside of the
building as well could you just go back
to that glass walls and ceiling because
that completely flummoxed me I'm sorry
this one you know so this is proposed to
be glass that would be a glass roof
lantern and again this is glass both
sides vertically by the side of that
walkway there a little walk little work
on existing buildings into the new part
of building yes exactly
I'll show you the floor plan on it and
maybe that will make it slightly more
clear so that's the glass walkway there
and that's just a section through this
part of the development there No
no sir this hasn't passed the bedroom
with a separate door and it isn't part
of the glass linked by a third party I'm
sorry I the question I asked for the
applicant was about the external
brickwork
[Music]
would it match I mean they're seen and
if we go back to the drawing that comes
from building you pulled up cows
fielding that one thank you are you
suggesting it will match the main feel
good existing the left hand the left
hand part of the building where the wall
that's going to be demolished well it
will and brickwork match that section of
the building if it's minded that this
would be approved we could add a
condition that the stonework could match
the existing and stable here and we
could also actually stone can have a
quiet life okay final question mr.
chairman sorry on the SPD it says that
to Hamilton pumping a minute ago I lost
a story it says that the application oh
sorry the extensions should normally be
avoided in in agricultural barns
it doesn't say should always be avoided
and I'm just wondering on what
circumstances would it be acceptable
under the SPP podgy when it would be
when it would be okay and when it
wouldn't be okay Victoria in front she
has that as a slide and she can show it
to members and you can see the precise
wording Victoria if you just gave that
up for us that would be helpful
yep yeah thank you thank you mr. BALCO
that's
yeah I have it on the screen I've known
also it was crazy so that's helpful when
would it be when would it be acceptable
I use I used to be a sting and maybe
expressionist mr. Barker I used to just
think it is very very rare and it's
acceptable
all right is just enough some that are
in some of the art in which case which
can be in which cannot be so as waiting
of part G it does say that small out
shirts or lean toes in a traditional
manner may however be acceptable to link
buildings domestic porches and other
small extensions will not be acceptable
so according to the this guidance only
small out shirts or lean tubes in the
traditional manner may be acceptable to
link buildings where necessary does that
does that answer your question yeah
that's quite I understand where you've
come from I'm not convinced that's quite
my interpretation that's why we have a
questions or should we move on to the
debate I can't see any indications no
right we'll move on to the debate on
this place he wants to start on this one
right is there anybody there can you
still hear me yeah I want to start right
cast the fielding thank you
I quite understand what the applicant
wants and that he wants to extend the
house but the tragedy of it is in my
book is that they haven't kept the
linear roofline across I noticed that
the new build is slight is slightly
wider or the proposed new build is
slightly bit wider than the existing
bond but you could easily keep the
linear look of it and maintain a more
acceptable building in my view the home
farm is a lovely setup the stables is a
nice setup but I'm afraid that I will go
along with the offices on the grounds
that it needs to be more in keeping with
the roofline rather more than the other
thing but um basically I'm happy that
they are putting an idea forward but I
think it's got to be in keeping with the
other buildings thank you q can sterling
counts the mils please
thanks mr. chairman yes I do John there
the it's laudable what the applicant
wants to do but I think it's just the
desire of it isn't it right I know they
were talking about the other house at
200 meters away or 200 yards away but we
can only look at this application which
in front of us and it is it is the
design I just wonder if if the applicant
could come back with a different disc
on the same materials at the old brick
whether we could look at that again and
I think it's just pure design so
unfortunately I can see why they want to
do it before she I'm gonna have to go
along with the author's recommendations
chairman thank you okay catch the minute
I've got catch the rock then catch the
honcho Seraphin please catch the rock
and then catch the kettle Thank You
chairman I agree with the previous two
speakers in that term I can see what the
applicant is trying to achieve but I
think I would go with the officers
recommendation with with the exception
of three words and clearly many of the
policies are breached by this proposal
the one I disagree with is by virtue of
its size its size is subservient to the
building because it's 49 or 50 square
meters opposed to a hundred so when we
get to this point and I'm happy to
propose this that were refusing on the
basis the office recommendation but it's
true I care of its size because like the
previous two speakers I think it would
be possible to come out with an
extension to the building that would be
acceptable but I don't think this
particular proposal is and I think it
would offer guidance to the applicants
in coming back with a different scheme
so that would be my suggestion and I'm
happy to do that in whatever is the
appropriate way to strike out of its
size
thank you champion thank you cast the
rock cancer I had to Seraphin been kept
the kettle police okay Thank You chair I
noted that the applicant said that would
be using matching bricks as near as
possible so it wouldn't detract from the
existing building at all I have no no
other complaints about the extension at
all thank you thank you kiss the cattle
you muted
mr. kettle Thank You mr. chairman
so I was looking at the Google Earth
again with respect this application I am
entirely convinced by counsel field
encounter Mills arguments on was all
cups of rocks because it is an isolated
building I've been through the you know
the SPD honest and I'm as I said I
wasn't entirely happy with in touch with
bitcoins interpretation of the wording
in that it isn't mandatory I don't think
that first sentence is mandatory you
cannot put an extension on I would die
without hi sorry I'm getting some
feedback feedback at the moment um that
might be me let me just see if I change
my settings I know the problem with my
sound sometimes I'll give me one sec
I'll time I'll whip a little bit right
yeah
uncle yeah I haven't got a problem with
an extension on this barn and when I
look at the layout of the extension
being at 90 degrees the existing bond
there is of course a matching layout to
the other side of the farm buildings the
main house which is likewise at 90
degrees and building so in that respect
I don't I don't know the problem with a
90 degree approach it just doesn't
affect quite as comfortably in for
setting you were different with the
different needs Heights and don't know a
ridge height that are higher in height
so the slope of the rulers would be
different and then you've got an
extension of the upstairs window which
again further sticks out which i think
is probably looking back at some of the
other designs is does site mr. carrot
backyard a sore thumb if you look at the
plan depict the proposed extension on
the planning application the existing
building the windows on the existing
building are not sort of attached to the
outside there level with the building
and in fact the side wall the upstairs
window is set in the wall it's not set
in front of me so
I'm actually happy with the principle of
development on this side
I just don't think to use the expression
you mr. chairman you too and others had
before I think Berkeley councillor
former councillor Williams if it isn't
quite right it's not right and I think
there is a bit of fine-tuning on its
application that would make it fit it in
very much more comfortably with the
existing buildings than this one does
I've got no problem with the class
warden ceiling I think that's a nice
innovation but if the building was to
continue the roofline in some form from
the existing building and not had
protruding that big protruding upstairs
window I would be actually have no
problems with it whatsoever
so another absolutely convinced but I'm
still on the cusp of going in support of
the officers recommendation on this one
very very aggressively
the kettle we've had a proposal from
catch the rock and I just want to
clarify something with mr. Barker he's
proposing to go along with the officers
recommendation for a refusal but with
the removal of of its size the proposed
extension by virtue of his size and
design fails to qualify how I'm just I'm
just looking for some guidance mr.
Barker on how would that materially
change their refusal I'm not comfortable
with with that but I understand what
pounds the rocks trying to achieve and I
think if you take out the words size and
it's actually achieved what counts to
the rocks after the proposed extension
by virtue of its design fails to qualify
as one of the exception blah blah blah
so it's deleting the words size and that
achieves what counts and Rob's trying to
achieve and I have no problem with that
bring you back in please
are you exactly chairman thank you
that's exactly the clarification I would
propose I misspoke by virtue of its
design first of qualifying because I'm
trying to send a signal to the
applicants which I think other members
have alluded to that I think another
design iteration of this might well
produce an acceptable scheme but I don't
think this one does so that's my
proposal that we try and make that
signal by addressing that in the reasons
for refusal so I'll make that proposal
German thank you how queer seconder for
what proposal catch the kettle you're
happy to second I'm happy to second but
I was going to make one
and that is I would go try this one mr.
Barker in in that we say and the Feldon
part clam special landscape area and
then we list all the core strategy s 1 9
12 and 20 and I'm just wondering if
we're trying to give a signal as the
Council Rock is suggesting with cs1 if
we're happy in principle with the run of
the cs1 is not a reason for a futile ds9
designed to pick the plus is exactly
what we are saying and and CS 12 I think
12 is just 20 I'm not convinced about CS
20 + CS 12 I think my only reason for
supporting comes with rock and I'll be
half and secondly if it was a limited to
cs9 purely on design terms and again
that is giving the signal to the
applicant if they were to submit a
revised application which fitted bore in
with notwithstanding what the coroner
said about no extension is acceptable I
think what we're saying is an extension
would be acceptable but it has to be a
more familiar design and therefore I
definitely take out CS 1 and I probably
take out SPS 20 I don't know come from
what we feel about that but if that sake
but that was seconded on that basis if
mr. Barker but of course it is happy
with that
mr. Barker had to fail that would
materially changed the recommendation
for refusal how would that with that
significantly diminish its weight
german-built bear with that's rather a
mouthful I haven't got to cs1 yet I
think I need several minutes to go
through your policies if you want a
detailed answer on that what you do have
in front of you is a recommendation that
thoroughly thought out if you wanted to
take out reference to a failed and
failed Beldon parkland special landscape
area I could understand that and I could
certainly agree to that and obviously
that would have takeout reference to
policy only one but the other policies
fragile have give me a minute to go
through the core strategy before I
comment if I could help you with that
cs1 is sustainable development I don't
what I'm suggesting to mr. rock is if he
wants to encourage the absence and cs1
it by saying this is sustainable
development it is saying development in
principle would be acceptable and but
actually it falls down on the design and
I think that's where I counted what was
coming from so I think my principle
issues probably if we just leave it at
sea s what removing cs1 sustainable
development
cancel the rock from any comments yeah
I'll see you're the original proposal I
have no strong views are they a bread
say s1 and it could be argued either way
I've deferred to to cancel the buy if if
Catholic Catholic muster emergency s1 I
wouldn't have a problem with that
amendment to what I had said if it wants
to be left in that could be argued as
well so I can get me with councillor
kettles proposal - I think we're all of
one my dear we're trying to send this
signal a difference P going to be
acceptable and this one isn't quite so I
think we're one mind it's just a
question of a rational way of doing that
so I defer to what mr. Barker advises
but I'm happy to attempt to cast the
kettle's recommendation of that minor
amendment as well
just a few more seconds if you were
chair and then I will respond to that
we'll just remind everybody he could you
wants the chat function or the hand
function on the system it would make my
life a lot easier if possible please
I don't always pick you up where you're
waiting because sometimes not sure where
you're combing your hair actually waving
or or swatting a fly that's gone through
the room so if you can use that it would
make it much easier for me please
you
okay German I have suggested that the
will of the meeting is that you
reference to the Feld Feldon partland
spectral landscape area and that
automatically takes out reference to
policy anyone sorry
I've understood that I've understood the
comment that counsel of a Ketel made
about CS 1 the the spirit of the meeting
that I'm hearing and similarly CS 12 but
I feel that cs9 and cs20 are both
directly relevant to the design and
therefore they should remain but of
course at the end of the day it's for
members to decide which policies they
feel are relevant to the decision but
that would be my advice that cs9 and
cs20 remain and reference to the park G
of the developments requirements SP
d-lister don't schedule I'm happy with
the suggestion mr. Barker's name if it's
the rock is unfair to anyone that tweet
proposal
Peter can you indicate again Cassandra
Seraphin yeah can you just reassure me
that policies are for guidance only
well it's good and they are there to
guide our decisions yeah yeah and
therefore you know we take on planning
and balance we look at each individual
application in detail and look at its
merits and therefore they are our
guidance and you know one day at one
post as once someone said to me one
person's trash is another person's
treasure not saying this application is
trash boy anyway but I'm trying to give
a metaphor there or similarly where we
can agree or disagree so just make that
clear I wasn't making any condescending
comments or differential and detrimental
comments about this upper case I was
just trying to give an example for
cancer edges serif and so hopefully
people to have that on board okay Ryan
co-chair absolutely support - sorry
I think it's important to expand on what
you just said we are required to decide
applications in accordance with the
development plan and less material
circumstances indicate otherwise so they
are not simply for guidance way beyond
that you are required to decide the
application in accordance with the
development plan but of course you are
allowed to interpret the developing a
plan as Ansel kettle has been doing I
think that was the point maybe was open
to interpret individual members
interpretation and that's why I try to
use that simile right so we've had a
proposal from counts of the rock and
seconded by Councillor kettle to refuse
the application with the amendments of
removal size and on the first line and
taking a fold in parkland special
landscaping area and quality CS 1 in CS
12 and policy any one meter cs9
keeping in 12
twenties is that right no no no the
other way
keeping it it's nine keeping in CS 20 oh
sorry I'll bring the wrong the wrong one
sorry apologize
come on the cut I say must know I used
to work with figures you work with words
as a lawyer I'll work with figures
apologies dad out no problem I just
remember future reference right right so
we've we've got prefers on the second
all those in favor of refusing this
application Olivia will we'll be going
round on so neat Thank You councillor
grant for councillor Mills
no some wheels for building the third
and we can't hear you might meet you
might good fine I'll come back to
Council if the old encounter Fleming
catch the Fleming for Seraphin if I say
for is that for the refusal yes
no grant yeah I'm against yep okay okay
fallen oppose or as amended by these
critters no they just scattered that's
four that's four yeah yet counter rock
for and back to councillor building yes
sorry counselor fielding sorry about
that the bar wouldn't come up showing
the meet the microphone I'm for refusal
ok chair that's six and one against
so Planning Committee be resolved to
refuse application number 20 / 0 0 5 f 1
5 1 6 first a few I'll thank you we'll
have a small recess so the officers can
now call in the next people for the
application so Olivia how long will you
need
um if we have three or four minute break
like if you could be back by 1932 please
and now that's not my year of birth
either so before we move on sir okay
we're going to meet all the mics now
thank you
okay I think we're ready to go back now
Oh hunt you Seraphin if possible because
you're sitting out of this application
can you mute your microphone and turn
off your camera please
we just need mr. Barker again if we can
when you want to indicate to speed would
be a lot easier again if you can make
sure before we speak again we're unmuted
but I did it so I'm not in a position of
strength so I'm just waiting for mr.
Barker
right we're all back now thank you move
on to the next item on the agenda which
is 19 slash zero one six though one /fu
I'll land off Reggie right studly
material change of use from vacant
stroke and agricultural land to
residential caravan site for two pitches
for occupation by gypsy traveller family
development with its associated hard
standing package tree and plant utility
blocks storage sheds and dog runs part
retrospective and our speaker will be
sorry I'll have the person introduce and
this will be Louise thank you very poor
guys can everyone see the screen hello
yes thank you yes this application was
deferred from the previous committee on
the 4th of March 2024 confirmation of
the medical condition of one of the
applicants this has now been confirmed
by the applicants doctor and was to
hospital
so what members can see before them is
at the application site which is
identified by the black dots on the map
and is located to the north of sturdily
town sorry I'm just going a bit of
interference there the application site
is identified by the site's aged in red
and is located within the West Midlands
Greenbelt and also the Arden special
landscape area it situated approximately
500 meters north of steadily built
barrier boundary a site lies within part
of a local wildlife site which is
located with which is within which the
side to situate
within here and a public right-of-way is
located approximately 200 meters west of
the site within an adjoining field
identified with dotted green line here
and a group TPO it is located our land
to the north of the site this is in
private ownership and not related to the
application site and the pink dotted
line denotes the county boundary
the EE application before members is a
retrospective planning commission or
planning application for the material
change of use of land into a caravan
site for to chips in traveler households
that's mister and missus look rich and
then three younger children which comply
comprised one household and their eldest
son and his wife is the second household
the site is proposed to comprised of two
pictures with space for a prosthetic
Caravan and utility building and space
for the parking of two vehicles within
each pitch for touring caravans and a
storage building are also proposed
on-site the applicant has identified in
the e4 to touring caravans to be
provided for accommodation for their son
and daughter who are of an age to
require separate bedroom accommodation
the other two tauranga caravans have
proposed to be used for travelling
purposes for each household a dog
kennels is also proposed within the
amenity area to the west of the proposed
hard standing and at present a temporary
enclosure has been erected in
southwestern enclosure however this is
not part of the application whilst not
shown on the plan six low level external
lights have also been erected within the
site the site is accessed off the reddit
Road here we go and following comments
from the highway authority the access
gate is being amended to incorporate a
separate pedestrian access to me enable
it to achieve a full sorry five meter
width
turning now to assume elevations of the
structures proposed these are plans of
the post timber short storage shed er
the top and bottom the dog kennels with
run this is a proposed elevation and
floor plan of the utility buildings so
one within each pitch turning now to
some photographs of the site this is a
view looking from ridge road so you can
see here the entrance and art within the
site which is now enclosed with a closed
ordered gate
this is the pedestrian access as well at
the side of the main entrance these are
the visibilities plays so this is a
northern visibility spray and this is
the southern visibilities place are
looking back towards Dudley you can see
the also the landscaping along the
frontage which is quite dense this is
the southern boundary of the site and
this is the first mobile home within the
development which replaces a previous
one on site showing the southern
boundary this now looks towards the
western boundary so this mobile home is
proposed to be relocated within this
vicinity here this is the temporary dog
enclosure in the western boundary post
and rail fence this is a view of the
northern boundary and you can see within
the the the trailer here this rolls of
turf which were going to be laid on from
site and this is a view from the public
footpath from the west of the site that
you showed the dotted green line earlier
on in the presentation and this is a
zoomed in view of that of that view so
again this closed boarded fence for the
dog enclosure will proposed to be
removed finally this is a view from an
access gate vehicle access gates were
the wider agricultural field which the
site situated within showing the
southern boundary so that's the end of
presentation and in summary therefore
the assessment of this development
proposal is its impact on the Greenbelt
and it's quite clear that this is deemed
to be inappropriate development
whereupon very special circumstances
were required to demonstrate required to
be demonstrated to outweigh the harm
there very special circumstances
provided or materially relevant in this
assessment and when one considers the
recently endorsed GTAA
a 2019 report
to find a need for up to 70 additional
pictures to 2035 in in combination with
the personal circumstances of the
appellants applicant it's considered
that there are clear and demonstratable
very very special circumstances that
outweigh the harm that justify the
granting of planning permission for a
temporary period as recommended in the
report Thank You chair Thank You Louise
yeah do you want to bring in the update
sheet so that there is the update sheet
which has sorry I don't have it in front
of me but too much to cut updates one of
the board member and just emitting a
sentence within his comments and then
the other is just two additional
comments received from third parties
yeah that's right yeah they they query
the delivery of an additional mobile
home on site so that's just the table
just so we've got a recorded voice of
the discussion right thank you the Reese
will move on to move on to our first
speaker which is Kent the Beeman
from Thank You general okay now
yes mr. Beeman yeah thank you for
getting this running tonight there in
the end thank you I think it was I think
I was probably the blocking agent
involved so it was thanks to the
officers who helped me out and helped
everywhere so we're the big shout out to
everybody involved thank you
and just against the pavement you're
representing study post cancel thank you
far away you've got three minutes and
we'll give you a warning with 30 seconds
here Thank You Chet remember supremacy
as you're aware this is their third time
the Basking business three reviews
following a long drawn-out process that
should have been completed by refusal
and enforcement Aston over 12 months ago
the effort into showing a total
disregard of planning law moving on to a
site without planning permission turning
a green field factor into travelers life
overnight they've even continued funding
development despite being advised not to
do so for the enforcement team the
occupants of Iraq's neighbors had
bonfires of reading attending Dobson was
discharged s first plunge in global
water brought and if you split lighting
and heart standing into an area that was
prevented by multiple pieces of wildlife
that they're no longer there society has
been open from destroyed in the green
belt in an area this camp for a rebound
prosperity designated as an important
right between sadly and Medich which
should be projected the councillors even
spent significant resources in
significantly fighting successfully by
things are coming up session to build on
an adjacent site the applicants
application should have refused with
their preferred with the he was
representative his objective while the
ward members and study parish been
important was clearly and contradict the
NPP air
members you've read their objections and
justification for refusal
which are well researched and based on
facts and policies the reasons given the
considering very special circumstances
but our needing medical attention while
immaterial if the child was ill and
needed special medical medical attention
wide mood from where they're where they
were before to a village with no
vacancies at the only doctor because
this a confession is accepted this will
become a policy that will carry weight
through it at the district if you decide
to graphic mission even tell about it
you will be given permission to anyone
to do the same anywhere in our district
that is something that you must agree is
totally unacceptable the parish can't
understand that there's an identified
need instead the district of public life
for these sites must come forward
through an adopted policy that has had
full meaningful consultation not like
illegal methods that totally disregard
existing policies and the several
community members we urge you to review
some information and instruct officers
it meant proceedings to foresee African
occupants severe cases though there is
no position any other decision even the
Tempe one shows the total disregard of
the MPPs
accepted and surrounding resident Thank
You Jay Thank You councillor Beeman
any questions for the post case of rate
I'm just trying to get back into our we
no questions are we happy
can I speak now no thank you catch the
Beeman you are free to go thank you
thank you good man thank you very much
parents the hunters teraphim did give
he's in the decorations of interest I
was not on a meeting he had objected as
ward member and is sat out from this
and it's part of that disclosure it was
agreed that we would read out his
representation from page 13 which child
will do no a plan application is cancer
pizza hunter Seraphin would member
object this planning application is on
green belt land and as they've already
moved on to the site with hard standing
plus mobile homes I will be strongly
objecting to this planning application
the Parrish cancer wall strongly object
to force many residents I guess I
thought I need to read that out
right anything else so obviously there's
no Christian is the ward member student
he's not here because of the reason
estimation Don is on the disclosure of
interest we will now move on to points
of clarification but the officer right
let's see who wants to go to the mill
sir please could you come in you've got
a question for the officer please yeah
yes Thank You Louise and it's this in
the green belt or not in the green belt
it is in the green belt okay yes that's
it for a moment thank you mr. Chen thank
you any other questions for cancer
kettle just came in front of closely
pockets the rock has the kettle please
[Music]
Louise you don't refer in your report I
may have missed it but I can't see
you're referring to the DC LG
application dated 2016 which supersedes
our core strategy and in particular
office is e and H of that document fee
for sake of clarification of Williams
travel sites in the Greenbelt and policy
H is determined planning applications
for mobile sites
and if I go to first one it says policy
$16 a paragraph 16 which is the first
policy in appropriate development is
harmful to greenbelt and should not be
prude and say except in very special
circumstances and then travel sites in
Greenbelt are inappropriate development
I sorry the best interest of the child
personal circumstances and unmet needs
are unlikely to clearly outweigh harm to
greenbelt if I go to paragraph 24 in
paragraph 8 on policy edge its varies
there that once again however is
paragraph 16 makes clear subject to the
best interest of the child
personal circumstances an unmet need
unlike it clearly outweigh harm to
greenbelt you want to omit that's funny
we robust language but you don't address
that publication from DC LG or 2016 in
your Ford could you could you explain
why
yes I'm just looking I mean like what I
do refer to is the Wow if you just go
back in terms of the assessment which
you refer to in terms of the greenbelt
policies and and the weight to be within
the weights to be attached to to the
level of farm which you're saying and
that is covered if you look at my
paragraph whilst not explicitly saying
about the ECL G 2016 document the same
assessments are made within the report
itself in terms of the weight to be
given with respect to the very special
circumstance is that within the green
belt needs to outweigh the harm but
caused by inappropriate Ness and any
other identified harm so it is covered
but it's not specifically identified in
terms of D CLG report um yeah I'm gonna
do your report is that the supersedes
our core strategy and and there's much
more focused isn't it sorry the detailed
report supersedes our core strategy and
is much more focused in that it's
actually almost shorter than our NCOs 21
scenario that I envisaged when I emailed
members two or three times over the last
week and asked them to give us their
questions in advance so that we could be
fully prepared and fully briefed to give
them answers and it's very disappointing
that counsel the cattle didn't follow
that advice and didn't give us adverse
warning I'm afraid I don't know what
document
about councillor kettle but I suspect
but it's a document that rests on the
back of the planning policy for traveler
sites the ppts which is clearly
mentioned in the report and clearly
taken to account in Louise's lose report
I can take you through in great detail
why it is appropriate given the current
policy situation grant permission for
this site the Chairman long story would
you like to go through that you remember
we mentioned it at the the chairs
briefing yeah I think that what I would
like to hear from you is the more detail
was just concerned in the 2019 GTAA
update which deserves the again touches
on it boxes on page 21 the report it
said it is a material consideration and
the assessment of this plan and
application that supersedes that the
2016 report that cares the kettle is
mentioned that superseded our 2015 core
strategy pleased oh gee taa identifies
anew 470 further gypsy pitches over the
period 2019 to 2035 within that period
which is what a 36-year breaks it down
and it's in the first five year period
2019 to 2024 we should be looking to
provide an additional 36 gypsy pictures
that's quite ambitious hidden the number
of gypsy pictures we have approved over
the last six year and it's quite
impatient given the number of gypsy
pitches we've approved over the last 18
points I think what that means
a serious problem providing housing or
gypsies the result district and that
means we give great weight to the need
for accommodation in this that's why the
recommendation is to approve because the
very special circumstances relate to
that black-op provision as I said I can
give you more detail if you wish but
that's a summary of it ok thank you for
that tale will now move on to catch the
rock please Thank You chairman I just
want to compare what the Parish Council
told us about the medical condition
compared with what's in the report on
that as that seems to be in one of the
key considerations as a very special
condition turn a phrase we're hearing a
lot of it says in the report that the
family do have a local GP whereas if I
understood it correctly the parish
council was saying well not quite the
opposite probably a.m. because he it was
spoken words the advantage of reading
the written words but it seems to be
clear in the report that whatever has
gone on in the past that this family do
have the need for medical attention
which is being fulfilled locally we're
absolutely clear about that are we
because the parish council seemed to
have suggested something different
through che yes I can confirm that I've
had a titled documentation both from the
steadily medical practice and also from
hospital as Worcester hospital so yes
that has definitely be confirmed
Thank You Joan right
any further questions to the officer
[Music]
okay cuz I'm not sure quite you mean
that Casa kettle a point is that point
of order or you want to raise a question
or well I'll expand mr. Barker I do
raise money man all this afternoon with
Reed Coleman ppts 2015 although it was
it was a variation on that cream so I
have sought to bring PPTs afternoon the
committee is very difficult to you know
after we do need to give the officers
noticed burn and one also the technical
issues and we are in the new normal with
virtual meetings so it wouldn't make it
lot easier for the officers to give them
the confidence in answer to your
question if they've got sufficient time
and expand on that so yeah I think you
all need to know that the future
reference technical questions to give
the officers as much notice as well
because obviously they've got there are
other jobs to do as well so if you could
bear that point in mind and we have
other jobs and I was chairing a full
meeting in Council on Monday which took
up a loss lost my time so I'm just
addressing mr. Barker asked for the
question advance the meeting I did raise
the issue PPTs for the 15 before the
meeting so mr. Parker disappointed mr.
Barnes appointed I'm sorry but I did my
best
labrum counselor careful related to a
document date of 2016 he was very
precise it was 2016 and he didn't give
its name and the document we're talking
about his 2015 the planning policy the
traveler sites it's it could potentially
be two different documents
the cattle needs to be precise and he
doesn't need to give us a little bit of
warning so that we can interpret his
words into actual planning policies
okay cast cattle carry on
we can't hear you now
Chris it was the 2015 document I'm sorry
mr. Barker I got one year I it is the
2015 document a PT SS document to which
I should have referred I apologize
I think that my outstanding question is
still there but obviously it's not
something which mr. Barker wants
progressed to address it please ask them
to on this this is really gonna add
something card I think we've had we have
spoken about the GTA i iet AI 2019 and
and what consideration that has special
circumstances and you know on this it
really adds on to the debate on to move
on the mills and catch the fleming with
some questions
catch the mills please Thank You mr.
chairman
oh my god through the the lads health I
suppose we're not privy to know what
that is I think what we could say is
we've received official confirmation
both from the medical practice the
hospital you've seen that no the office
just have a dive Steve written
confirmation both from the Medical
Center I believe Louise if I got the
wrong one and the hospital as well
confirming his condition so we're
satisfied with is Louise page 19
paragraph apologies Mike I don't have a
document sorry yeah I'll read it out to
you said
I consider that at present the visual
impact of the site on its surroundings
with result in a degree of conflict with
policy cs5 and CS 12 and would result
some harm to visual amenities of the
Greenbelt so sorry it is yes he count
the parent numbers and tell me so it's
just - but it's the paragraph above
number three residential amenity thank
you sir oh thanks man you sir have you
got it now
number three presidential immunity it's
the paragraph about that
starts off I consider that oh sorry yes
thank you
it's we don't have page numbers on our
document okay yes um yeah thank you
yeah I'm just saying is it I mean uh
you're saying this has got a bad effect
on the local surroundings but what I say
is that yes I acknowledge them
historically there was effectively
Greenfield in that location in the green
bouncing it's a special landscape area
as well and what I do acknowledge is
that the development and its current
form and proposed form will have an
impact on the landscape and so it will
have a degree of harm however I do go
within the body of that assessment
identify that there is quite mature
landscaping along the frontage of the
site from reddit Road there is very
little scope for viewing the site from
Green Lane and and the only other
visible impact from from public vantage
points is the 200 meter away public
on another side of a quite dense
hedgerow and a chantrey border so yes
there is harm it has a degree apart of
the openness of the of the Greenbelt in
visual impact assessment but that is
with the additional landscaping as well
proposed as part of conditions reduces
its level so we acknowledge it bricks on
balance because of the benefits that
going to results in terms of the
five-year housing last applying the
personal circumstances of the applicants
and also the educational benefits of
having a settled base those are all
elements which weighed in in terms of
the factors okay thank you very much you
explain though extremely well Louise
thank you very much it was worth the
wait
Louise yeah just a simple clarification
really when we yet we deferred this
meeting sort of back in March time and
one of the reasons we deferred it was
that it was the proximity to read each
hospital that was the necessity Louise
has been mentioning Worcester hospital
which is like 16 miles away and just
wonder if she could confirm it's still
Worcester and not read it yes I can't
and the reason why Worcester Hospital
has been referred to is that the
applicant had submitted documentation
from his previous medical appointment
and well one relatively recent one and
he's been going to Worcester so this is
why it allows him to have a more settled
base being in this location because
he'll then be able to go to the Redditch
hospital see okay one of the very quick
question has there been many objections
from local residents in Green Line there
have been objections from local
residents some of them are remain
anonymous
yes that there have been local concerns
okay thank you for the question thank
you
no further questions no right we'll move
on to the debate now who wouldn't wants
to start on this
it's all quiet any anybody
catch the males
Thank You mr. chairman I love it we're
between the rocket of our players here
and if we go to refuse this application
we could seem like a hard-hearted
counselors because you know we're not
looking after the interest of the young
of the lad and I I don't know how but
also concerned that when they did move
on to the site the new web condition is
and I knew where the facilities were
this is I don't know why they did it why
didn't they move nearer to you know
somewhere where he'd get proper
facilities so I'm a little bit I am
concerned about this and the fact in
retrospective as well they've moved on
yeah and we've had enforcement down
there and now we're saying I'm good wait
to see what the other cows have the
council's have to say on this mr.
chairman but I'm just a bit concerned
thank you
yeah don't know where you noticed it is
for a temporary three-year permission
yes I did see that yes yeah and
obviously we have to make sure we go to
our policies as well and the GTI 2019
like counts for Mills I'm very concerned
about this it is the green belt and if
they got to put our main sewer in it's
going to make it very difficult to put
the land back after three years to the
state it was before I fear we've got to
go one way or t'other and I had a lot of
problems the last time we had Rock
camera
on this one a for the greenbelt be our
policy on providing accommodation for
the traveling community so I I just
don't know which way to vote as with
Miss councillor Mills I wait to hear
what everyone else can say against the
kettle priest Thank You mr. chairman
the GTAA 20 the 2019 document which has
been opted by Kavanagh since September
last year does define areas in the
district which would be appropriate for
Egyptian traveler sites and that is on
page very early on in the document this
area is not with him with that it
doesn't fall within the the identified
area I did quote earlier on from the
2015 application from leasing og which
said that not the standing which five
children's interests it is very
difficult to see where a gypsy traveller
site going back to that policy could
outweigh the damage to the Greenbelt so
we have two I'll quote subject the best
interest of child
personal circumstances an unmet need
unlikely to a clearly outweigh harm with
a green belt and any other harm so as to
establish very special circumstance now
I understand that the patient is not
actually a child he is one all of the
families children but he is over the age
of being a child
so if we follow the guideline of 2016
and they sir I apologize my onea date of
2016 the DC og policy statement is quite
clear but personal circumstances are
unlikely to outweigh the damage for the
green belt so clearly there is the
personal circumstances to the family are
very important therefore it is a very
difficult one we have to match up
perfect or fo for the fancies of an
adult is not referred to in the 2015
document and the 2015 document is
corporate cross reference to include
options we've adapted adopted so we are
we are we have a breach of green belt
policy we have an iron area of the
district which is identified as suitable
crickets in traveler sites and this does
not fall into it and we have an adult
who does have health care needs so where
do we go we recommend you to support
this application on the temporary basis
even though the vlg quite clearly says
personal site
circumstances are unlikely to outweigh
the harm to the green belt I'll leave it
at that
at the moment I might come back of my
mind then I'll bring down in the one
issue that you didn't mention is a lack
of five years of life for gypsy in
traveler sites you know it's comparable
so I'm led to believe and I'm sure mr.
Barker will put me right if on
I'm speaking out of turn it's comparable
to the luck of fog ahead and none supply
in the core strategy so so hold on then
I'll get Dale to come in so therefore we
do have to consider that is you know in
the past where we've had applications
where we didn't think it was suitable
for development of
Jibson travel site of an ordinary
development and because we hadn't got a
five-year house in nan supply and it was
in the sustainable location we had to
grant the application so I'll see very
similar comparators between the two but
this time it's gypsies and travellers as
opposed to the residential development
and the county in our district so mr.
barkis you want to come in please
thank you yes you I think you've hit e
bang on the head I have a copy of the
planning page planning policy for
traveler sites available and I can put
it on the screen if you wish the
counselor kettle has certainly been
reading from it and certainly been
reading the policies of it well he
hasn't been doing is reading from policy
CLE which as you rightly say poops
housing for gypsies on the same footing
but housing for non gypsies in other
words you need to have a five-year
housing land supply and you've seen from
the the GTA figures that we discussed
earlier that we do not have a five-year
housing loan supply and members who are
on committee previously will remember
the great way that inspectors gave to
applicants to the lack of a five-year
housing land supply when they were
considering appeals for conventional
housing and officers are advising you
that they will give the same weight to
the lack of a five-year housing land
supply for gypsies and that's why we are
giving great weight to that element
these people these gypsies he phrase
that the gypsies resorting to Stratford
require accommodation that we are not
providing right catch the kettle and
Kesler up mr. Jarrell I absolutely agree
with you and I agree with to some extent
with mr. Barker that we created having a
five-year housing and supply we know us
to peel our appeal after appeal where
applications were a few but not in the
greenbelt the vast majority of all those
appeals we lost were in non green belt
land and I did check this out earlier on
today with mr. Nash a place mr. Nash
correct me if I'm wrong but in within
the green belt the green belt policy was
something which inspectors were whether
very or or not but the tidal wave that I
think European
Sherman was outside the Greenbelt not
remember result the Greenbelt continue
to have significant protection during
that period when our normal fire hunting
land supply was unfulfilled so I think
it's to members to make this decision on
on whether this five-year house and land
supply for gypsies and travellers allied
or in addition to the very special
circumstances of the applicant I wised
the harm to the Greenbelt
and then that would be that's the plan
imbalance and then members will be able
to make their decision on whether one
outweighs the other or vice versa so I
think it'd be then for members to decide
what their views are whether to refuse
or grant this application based on their
opinions on the five-year housing land
supply the Greenbelt and the very
special circumstances plus all the
material matters that are in the report
as well so I'll move on to the
Rockcastle flooding just clarify the
relevant test is would the adverse
effects of Approval significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
that's the test you've got to apply and
obviously you can come to any conclusion
you wish but that's the test
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
Thank You chair thank you
all right Casper up please Thank You
chairman I mean the judgment that are on
saying here is clearly there are many
elements of this that are making
unsatisfactory application were it not
be for the special circumstances of the
lack of supply and the personal medical
circumstances of one of the occupants
the recommendation before us to grant it
has got 16 conditions that we as a
committee can apply giving us an element
of control not not least the three-year
life of the approval I though I'll take
entirely the view of Pat the main sewer
if we were to refuse this presumably
there is a risk that the applicants then
appeal and the panel inspector takes a
different view and we might as an
authority get less control over the
application so that that is a judgment
that we have to make is to whether we
choose to allow this permission with
those fairly stringent controls on it or
refuse it and then have the possibility
that it gets overwritten by an inspector
on the basis of those special conditions
that have been outlined to us on
officers so it does make it a very
difficult decision which of course is
why we've got it in the first place but
defer to hear what everybody else has to
say the joys of being on Planning
Committee
Thank You chairman and if there were
gonna be council provided sites and
whatever they'd become sortation about
where these things were placed and now
these guys have taken it into their own
hands to find themselves somewhere now
having lived in Biddeford I've seen the
results of what happens if you haven't
got a five year land supply and the
problem is that once the five year land
supply gets approved you've still got
all the houses that you didn't want in
the first place and even if the the five
year supply comes up later on for gypsy
and traveler sites these people will
still have an unwanted sight
adjacent to the houses so I think the
for me the the benefits over the the
harm to the Greenbelt I don't think they
outweigh but that is a personal choice
so from my perspective and I wouldn't be
supporting the grants a situation in
this darling thank you the fielding I
ever since I've been on the Planning
Committee I've argued that I fear the
Greenbelt really does dictate
development in this part and so
therefore all the areas to the west east
get it right of Stratford seem to get
all the development in this case I think
we've got to make an exception that
we've to allow this development to take
place it's got the problems of a we've
got to have our five-year land supply
which has been referred to it does harm
the Greenbelt but on the other hand it I
I fear because it's there there's not a
great deal we can do about it and we
will not be able to rescue the land or
they will not be able to rescue the land
and bring it back to pasture so I'm I
fear I don't like retrospective planning
applications that I go along with the
planning officer and I propose that we
accepted thank you mr. Nash yep I'd just
watch one comment and that there are
long stay it has been mentioned there
are stringent conditions if we remind
you to prepare agree this recommendation
to what Joe my point was just go back to
Council of Fleming's point I think Daryl
can help me out on this but I think
we're behind on our total loss of years
and if thou could just just explore 12
just
and on the total that where we should be
at the moment on the number of gypsy
pitches okay yes yeah I mean the target
is for a five-year period so what we
needed to be is my twenty twenty twenty
four we sort of found thirty-six gypsy
pitches over a five-year period which
means in the last eighteen months we
should have found something like I don't
know 11 pitches and over the last 18
months of think we've approved one we
certainly haven't approved more than one
well I appreciate that science can come
forward with multiples of pitches on but
we do seem to be behind the curve here
in only approving one in an 18-month
period there's any more I can say than
that yep
right thank you for that we we've had I
would say mind motivator is yet the
five-year lack of supply is quite
telling
yes it's it's there are pros and cons
for this on more sure there is its
temporary information for three years
with stringent conditions and named
occupants as well so that would be I
would be reassured by that so that's so
all would be supporting the
recommendation we've had a proposal from
councillor fielding to grant this
application I'm looking for a seconder
if nobody wants the second it I will
second the proposal
catch the kettle I've got we've got to
propose in a second can we make this
brief and a question to mr. Barker then
please before we go to the vote thank
you in two years or even three years
time we have a five-year spikes apply
elsewhere in the district would that
mitigate against any extension on this
site as it is in the green field
I thought that ought to be brief to give
a brief answer chair yes it would
certainly strengthen your case I can't
say no more than that but equal to take
strengthen your case
you
right we've had the vote we've had a
proposal to grant application and I've
second that proposal will need to go to
the vote
Olivia will you be working your magic
with the poorest place for animals
against cancer the fielding I think
you're muted cancer field and we're
going to rein in counts the rock abstain
chair that's two votes for one vote
against and two abstentions
you don't get a chance to vote cats of
Fleming
sorry counts of seven counts of lemon I
thought about okay I thought we were
someone catch the flu me against okay
chess that's two for two against and two
abstentions
so it goes with many with the custom
vote too
I will still go with my original
decision to grant the application and
ask further for the recommendations in
the report so therefore that means the
committee resolves to grant mr.
application 19 facts zero one six zero
one fu out with the conditions that have
been I think it's 16 conditions that are
in the report I will just check the
number yes yes and the two notes thank
you for that and again if we could have
a small break while Democratic services
causing the speakers for the next item
so again two minutes to stretch your
legs and then come back for the next
application thank you
you
join my parish council meeting tonight
in Kyneton on zoom' well you couldn't
you capture computers and do them both
at the same time I've got another one
here but they probably finished by now
they start half seven camos sorry I know
the signs gone off to say the meetings
adjourned it is still alive meeting okay
thank you thank you
you
I'm having a terrible problem battling
with these earphones to keep so I can
get the best able to hear yeah what
everyone's saying councillor fielding is
that you okay we've muted you cancel
because it's still a live meeting
if you if you need to speak to us you
can perhaps put it in the chat
you
you have everybody heard that and if you
do miss speeds offices can you put in
the chat please
we are still alive a moment well
you
right you can just throw we'll need two
seconds
you
you
right move on to our last item on the
agenda we just take the three our role
in case it does run over the next
application yeah obviously they've used
quite right indeed we've been going on
two and a half hours officially now just
over we do we can't stop the meeting
after three hours but I propose that we
carry on past the if necessary carry on
past the trio so we can hear the next
application in full on looking for this
summary to second that application can I
just interrupt please chair we are
supposed to do it on the actual three
hours and not before I just saw a bit of
a bit of clarification for the
monitoring officer and it has to be on
three hours whether we're halfway
through an application all right trying
to be you know trying to be clever
rather than doing it half way through
and stopping an inadvertent point but
apologies apologies to Olivia but yeah
I'll just have a look at the
Constitution it does say three hours
there you must take the vote okay that's
fine thinking no problem I did my best
Olivia sorry about that
and right now move on to our final
application of the night which is 2000
won three night slash ful land adjoining
green waste temple Grafton use of land
the stationing of caravans for
residential purposes the one numbered
gypsy pitch and two parabens one marble
homer one sword in conovan together with
the formation of hard standing and
utility stroke during ancillary to that
use and creation of a new access
existing to be closed right please Thank
You chairman I'll just share the
presentation with you so the site lies
in Temple Grafton which is designated as
another settlement in the core strategy
indicated by the black dot on the plan
the site lies outside of the physical
confines of Temple Grafton adjacent to
the boundary of the most westerly
property known as greenways which is
here the one pitch gypsy site will
occupy a small part of the eastern end
of a wider field outlined in blue which
appears to be an agricultural use so the
application site itself is outlined in
red the longer lines along the frontage
are the visibility displays the proposal
includes the closure of an existing
access in the southeastern corner and
the creation of a new access and
permeable hard standing space for a
mobile home highlighted purple a touring
Caravan dark pink and the dayroom
in lighter pink is proposed with
landscaping to the boundaries the day
room itself would have a rich height of
5.6 meters and B of brick and tile
construction with dimensions of 5 by 8
meters in terms of the footprint so the
west of the site is Ogden's Grafton the
core of the village here and to the
sorry the east to the west is Arden's
Grafton also designated
and other settlements the existing five
pitch site in Croft Lane lies to the
north of the village the conservation
areas of Temple Grafton are highlighted
here outlined in pink and the
conservation area at Arden's grafted to
the west highlighted in pink public
right-of-way networks and run all around
the site but predominantly adjoining the
site is public right-of-way SD 10a which
links to the wider network you'll also
note that the shaded light green area
around the site here particularly along
the front boundary forms the edge the
southern edge of the odd and special
landscape area as the proposed plan
highlights societies within an area at
risk of surface water flooding shown on
this plan the Environment Agency online
maps show the extent of flooding in the
area and the access falls within an area
of identified as a medium risk as thus
the submitted flood risk assessments so
to put the site into its context this is
a photograph of the existing access to
the site that would be closed and
replaced further along the road this is
the existing stable building within the
site adjacent to the boundary of green
race this is a view from the site
looking west towards Arden's Grafton and
this is a view looking east back from
Arden's Grafton direction and where the
car is shown there and the mature tree
the access is proposed just beyond that
point it doesn't result in the removal
of the trim this is a view of the public
right-of-way
the footpath to the north of the site
you can see a slight slope in the land
across the wider Blue Nile is probably a
slope of between three to four metres
but within the site itself less than a
meter this is a view from the top end of
the public right-of-way looking back
towards the site you can see there the
roof of greenways and the outbuilding
and also on the left-hand side there's
the church
in the village and this is a view
zoomed in of the property known as
greenways the outbuilding here and the
site just sits in behind this header ooh
that's the end of the presentation Thank
You chairman thank you sorry I just
summarized in summary in the assessment
of this proposal home has been
identified to varying degrees in respect
of the impact on the art and special
landscape area visual immunity and
temple graphed and conservation area has
also been identified in respect of
flooding and residential immunity but my
report makes it clear that these can be
mitigated by conditions therefore taking
into account the lack of the five year
supply off sites the recently endorsed
gypsy and traveler accommodation
assessment report identifies the need
for up to 70 additional pictures to 2035
it is considered that there are clear
and demonstrable benefits that outweigh
the harm that justifies the granting of
planning permission for the proposed
site in the sustainable location that's
the end of my presentation thank you
there has been a update significant
update sheet with this application
members read that are very happy with
would you like me to summarize any of
those yeah I think just you just
summarize just to make sure okay so
there are a number in in the update
sheet firstly a couple of corrections to
the report in terms of some wording and
secondly the comments from the bleed
local flood authority further to my
discussions with them confirming that we
can condition surface water flooding and
potential caveat there in terms of the
treatment of such disposal of surface
water also conditions updates in
respective condition1 and condition2
Edition 10
following on from the comments of the
lead local flood authority and we also
had an additional third-party
representation it was quite extensive a
lot of the comments made have been
summarized in my reports as they were
raised by residents the letter was on
behalf of Grafton residents and it does
raise a couple of discrepancies between
the site plan and proposed layout plan
which I have looked at and they wouldn't
prejudice this development coming
forward or result in the development
being on a different part of the site it
doesn't fall within the redline also
some unknowns of the application which
the residents do not agree can be dealt
with by condition again my report looks
at those issues and the update also
addresses those while some of the areas
of agreement are noted in this
representation there are comments on
possible lack of quantity comments but I
have received comments from those that I
did consult with and also youngling a
critique of the assessment by the
officer question raised over the number
of pictures to meet needs and their
conclusion on balance in this case the
negatives significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the positives contrary to my
recommendation Thank You chairman I just
emailed you them as well so you do need
to look at those thank you right well
move on to our first speaker which is
hence the Mary Ann witty from Temple
Crafton parish council welcome catch the
bitty are you with it
Massimo got the wrong just checking up
hello is that you've got three minutes
we'll give your warning with about 30
seconds and please stay on the line for
any questions from from any the
counselors on the committee so far away
please coach in this application which
harm our villages and a high quality
landscape these are all masses which our
country to the policies of the district
councils own core strategy firstly this
development will adversely impact the
scenic quality of an area in the Arden
SLA secondly the visual immunity and
character of the street scene will be
harmed there's a loss of the historic
unbroken hedge between the two villages
thirdly you need to being outside the
physical confines of Temple Grafton this
development will be at odds with the
undeveloped and open character of the
area and inconsistent with the landscape
firstly the fact which I cannot accept
the fact which I believe cannot be
emphasized enough that this development
encroaches into the undeveloped gap
between two unsustainable villages as
she's known these times of country from
CS 12 5 and 9 of exactly in all the five
sites be in an area free of budding
which is an issue here this development
policies in the council's core strategy
and it is staggering that it should have
been recommended to the grounds in the
first place the only reason you are
having to consider this application
given the substantial harm the case
officer has identified is due to the
lack of a gypsy and traveler plan for
the district ten years ago five ships
attentions were granted to the north of
Temple Grafton again both the case
officer and Inspectorate conceded that
the site was not suitable and with
harmful to the open countryside nature
of the area unlike this application it
does not have the additional issues of
the encroachment between two villages or
impact on when the neighboring property
the application was given
permission and eventually granted
permanent citizen appeal because of this
kind of like old temporary because this
train for black Egyptian traveler pass
those villages affected by this
development certain sizes other
settlements in the course actually there
is no shop and no daily public transport
links the only immunity is the primary
school they are not as evidenced by
numerous planning decisions made by
Stratford district council considered
unsustainable villages policy see s21
identifies the [ __ ] site should be in a
sustainable location however the report
makes reference to this site not being
considered unsuitable for a Dipsy shape
site surely if this application is
granted an Ergo considered sustainable
then developers will be able to use this
inconsistency in their favor this parish
council has a track record of not
supporting anything new development
accessible is going to be based on our
experiences here that this tempie
permission will ultimately become more
than one family unit this is highly
likely to want more than one pitch we
understand you have a difficult task it
is the fact that there's an identified
need for gypsy sites in the districts
but this is not the right location we
implore you to list the negative impacts
of this application the adverse impact
in the line state can not be overstated
we ask you to do the planning - balance
and significantly outweighing the
deduction and district site needs by one
thank you thank you cancel it any
questions for the parish council place
the petal you're waving yep
please can you come in thank you just
taking the time to unmute tell me where
the nearest sorry
as cattle can you type it into chat and
I'll read at the moment if you do that
can stir kettle type it into the chat
arm will read X I can't hear you very
well it's coming across
in the meantime cancer fellow Dean's got
a question for the parish counselor can
stir kettle gets the fielding just
unmuting does temple Grafton in the
neighboring village do you have built up
area boundaries around your villages and
so you're aiming to keep the gap between
the two two villages they're not trying
to bring them in operation are you in
the Greenbelt we are not in the thank
you and are you other villages listed or
conservation area thank you thank you
you're muted counselor you're muted Andy
you better know if you want to but could
you tell me where the nearest
thank you thank you
the questions for the know I'll get some
three buk committee members confirm I
can hear me okay yeah yes I can aim
thank you very much thank you cancer
you're free to go but can you stay with
us and see what happens right thank you
when they move on to our next next
speakers which is Helen keys and the
zine Boclair and again apologies if I've
mispronounced any names there yeah yeah
hello we are here
Bojana and Helen and we're going to
share the three minutes
one after another okay
we'll give you a warning with 30 seconds
to go and he could stay with us after if
you stay with us after you finish
speaking because there may be some
questions for you we submitted some
slides as well and I think they could be
perhaps show yep I'm hoping they're
shown many with shared with screen can
you see the slide entitled one
recovering flooding at greenways now we
can't see them yet yes we can see them
okay if we if you talk to try and talk
to the slides if you can if you can will
tell you the first one is recurring
flooding at Green why's first of October
2019 and there's pictures of the garage
of a property and a house being flooded
yeah right thank you
okay it's like 1 & 2 please our
objection is not anti [ __ ] the field
one question is unsuitable for any
development due to flooding as residents
of greenways for the last 3 years we
have experienced several instances of
surface water flooding from the field in
2017 and being and a major one in
October 29th seen as like three please
the proposed development will be highly
visible from our house which was
adversely affect privacy because of the
elevated position of the field moving
the dayroom to 10 meters from our
friends would make it even more visible
from our house we are concerned that if
the permission for the site is granted
the noise from activities in the field
such as the recent quad bike riding
would increase substantially and prevent
us and our neighbors from enjoying this
peaceful location this would diminish
our quality of life and adversely affect
our human right to peaceful enjoyment of
our property thank you but this is also
a broader issue for the villagers of
Temple Grafton our
Grafton shown by over 80 objections
submitted and that residents have
appointed an independent planning
consultant whose report has been sent to
you life for clean
we proudly belong to two separate
villages but this application extends
the village of temple Grafton towards
Ardath Grafton in contravention of
policy cs9 like five the site is
bordered by a public footpath to the
north it's something used by many
villagers and dog walkers particularly
on their way to the tranquil Nature
Reserve part of the Army's special NAND
gate area
the site is elevators and prominent
occupying undeveloped lands the
application is therefore contrary to
policy CS twelve five six pavements to
the south of the site is the main path
connecting the two villages and is a
popular busy thoroughfare particularly
Enomoto the route is part of a safer
walk to school program supported by RMP
the proposed opening of the access will
harm the continuous nature of the
hedgerow between the two villages slide
7 we asked why so little progress has
been made to improve the provision of
gypsy and traveler sites in the ten
years since we last those digits the
application a site granted despite our
village not being a local service
village has any consideration even been
given to expanding that site by one
pitch instead of creating this new site
sorry
our own 20:19 having new survey
demonstrating no need for gypsy and
traveller pitches this is not just an
issue for the Grafton's
by giving such unwarranted emphasis to a
single issue of unmet need the Planning
Department has made this a broader issue
for the whole of the tracts of districts
if this case whether harm so
significantly and demonstrably outweighs
the benefits is granted we should all be
extremely concerned that this will open
the floodgates to any speculative
developer to propose gypsum traveler
pitches in inhaler location thank you
the mutant Andy you're muted Andy yatin
back there thank you
what I just said was really really
excellent but unfortunately I can't
remember what I said there
okay so thank you guys you're spot on
councillor Mills would like to ask you a
question please
yeah yes Thank You mr. chairman
has there been any approach by the
applicant to the parish council at all
on this on this site any presentation
being made I think for you're asking of
where the residents I think perfect I'm
sorry so yeah it was pretty previous
ones were the parish council I have
sorry are thinking catch the mill start
attempting this question has the village
been made aware of any consultation or
any representations from we've not been
made of any be made aware of any
representations by the by the askin that
mean obviously everyone is aware of the
planning application that's why there
were over 80 objections and I think is
the overwhelming response of the
villagers in both temple Grafton and
Arthur's grass and that I think was just
complete shock but you know this would
be considered a suitable site yep that's
going thanks very much
any other questions for the objectors I
got one you mentioned the safer routes
to school and it went quite quiet then
so I didn't quite hear what you said I
think it might have been had and was was
talking about that if you could cut back
on that please I apologize it was a bit
crackly on me so I didn't quite hear
what he said the pavement which is to
the south of the site goes directly past
it's the main cast way between the two
villages and obviously there are a
number of children in Ozma crafter and
he walks to temple grass and then in
fact much time and effort has been
spent over the last few years on
improving the safety of that so there
are for example lots of new markings
outside the school so carbon not allowed
to park by the school now in fact cars
would now have to park back across the
entrance to this site but also you know
what we're saying is there would be a
number of people walking past this site
so it would be highly visible to many
many of the villagers and in addition
when people walk along they walk along
this beautiful continuous hedgerow that
connects the two villages which would
now have a gap within it to create the
new access to the field so I think again
you know people feel for a number of
reasons both safety of the children
walking across it when there could be
traffic coming in and out but also just
the visual aspect of it that it wouldn't
be suitable okay yep thank you thank you
for not curse the kettle thank you was
Joan looking at Google Earth and I did
was it beside a couple of days ago
obviously not on the site appear to be a
number of what could be concrete pads
running along the normals hedge roam
about a shortness and sinful nature
could you explain what they are you
might be able to see them coming up from
your house I don't know about 10 meters
from home decided that he would put in
these concrete basis which no you know
he didn't make any application for them
as far as we are aware he didn't make
any I don't believe he spoke to the
parish council about that at all he put
those bases in everyone was very
concerned as to what they were but then
he sold the land and he sold the land to
the new applicant
cats careful you meet it again still
Chris it's also good at muting me that
the no enforcement action was taken that
it by strawberry council against the the
what you're describing is an authorized
works I just wondered how it was the
previous owner I'm just wondering I
can't see the relevance of to this
application council kettle the link on
the site that's been there without
permission it's not developed land so I
just wondered what the relevant to the
point was really yeah well it doesn't
relate to the owner it relates that any
enforcement relates to the land not the
owner and therefore I was just inquiring
as to whether we had taken any action
against that it's not nothing to do with
the previous owner no I was just asking
for clarification what they were thank
you all right thank you for that I still
still didn't quite understand the
relevance of the enforcement but we'll
move right
I think ladies there's no further
questions thank you for your clear and
concise answers and presentation please
stay with us while we move on to our
next speaker and that next week is
counselor mark Cargill who is the ward
member case the cargo can you hear us
please can't hear you very well that's
the cargo you're quite quiet
you
Oh can you hear me oh that's much better
thank you - housing key so far away when
you're ready please not far tonight
thank you very much heed members you've
already heard about the
inappropriateness of this site for [ __ ]
trouble accommodation the council has a
responsibility to provide the right type
of accommodation the right place for the
right reasons this is none of those the
information provided in the application
is sparse to say the least we cannot be
sure the applicant is the future
occupier of the pitch and the officer
report questions were the applicants
satisfy the definition of a gypsy
traveller yet the planning statement
states that there will be children
living on the site no evidence had been
provided to support the statement the
application is therefore accurately
described by the officer as speculative
there is a flood risk assessment
attached however as noted in the report
it fails to mention that flooding has
occurred at the site a number of times
as evidence in the previous presentation
in my opinion we cannot therefore give
that report any credibility these six of
our very recently adopted climate change
as PD states that developments should be
adopted to cater for the anticipated
extreme weather events such as splitting
no mitigation measures have been
proposed for the scheme such as such
scheme on urban drainage system I note
that there is no accepted plan for the
removal of sewage off site the officers
included a condition to ensure this is
implemented
however as reported we cannot be certain
of what scheme will be brought forward
and as noted there may be harm to the
roots of trees and shrubs the village of
temple Grafton is within the Arden
special landscape area the clue is in
the title we should not be diminishing
our beautiful and limited resource by
allowing inappropriate development of
any kind here I have real concerns over
the blurring of the boundary between the
two villages although only one pitch is
proposed at the moment more of course
can be applied for that would severely
impact on the character and open
of the area the site is between 50 and
90 meters from the conservation area of
Temple Grafton
there are 28 listed buildings in the
village the closest being the school is
called cottages this could be considered
as a reason for refusal the site as
demonstrated will be visible from a wide
area the planning statement states that
plans and individual elevations of
caravans are not required
I suggest that given the sensitivity of
the proposed medication that such plans
and elevations are essential we have
heard that simple grafting is not a
service village and as such not a
suitable a sustainable location for
development of this nature this will
lead to the use of a car so that cuts
across v3 the climate changes PT agreed
by this Council on Monday this week
coalescence the site is outside the
accepted built-up area boundary and thus
such as open countryside it extends the
built form of the village towards
several grafting bleeding to occur
essence I have real concerns over the
loss of hedgerow a significant rural
feature this is effectively leading to
urbanizing the open countryside on the
subject of the head right edge I also
have concerns over the business of
visibility splay is required resulting
in yet more removal whilst the planning
statement dismisses the needs that
define visibilities blaze this is a 60
MPH Road and therefore road user safety
must be taken to account due to the
inappropriateness of the site the
pitches and out-building have had to be
shoehorned into a space adjacent to the
neighboring property this would be
unacceptable under all circumstances so
why allow it here
the neighbors are entitled to quiet
enjoyment of their rural setting this
does not meet our criteria a good design
members in martes year planning
application 18 star 0 1 1 6 / 4 was
refused permission that application site
is two miles from here in the same SLA
the reason for refusal were harm to the
landscape character setting a realistic
building and failure to demonstrate a
viable service water drainage solution
sound familiar
this scheme has only reached this stage
due to the lack of a five-year housing
plan supply for pitches why we do not
have such a supply is a real concern the
inclusion of one pitch however is not
going to solve that issue but it could
lead to significant harm to our lovely
countryside members unmet need and a
lack of a housing five-year life supply
our material considerations but the
material reasons for refusal
significantly and demonstrably override
that lack of a five-year housing blind
supply for this speculative application
I therefore urge you to refuse planning
permission for this application of all
the reasons demonstrated this evening
and I will refer to as identified in the
report CS 1 4 5 8 12 21 and not
forgetting para 170 of the NPP F Thank
You members sinky I thought I'd let you
finish so kind yes Annie I've got cancer
Mills wants to ask you a question
Mason we started at 6:20 so we'll start
would to take the vote and the vote in
10 but I'm happy to take it now 3 hours
live so do it now ok so if you can just
um confirm everyone's halfway out do
roll call
yes how pleased to carry on to Mel's yes
happy to carry on building yes carry on
Fleming yes quite happy to carry on
Chancellor hunter Seraphin yes happy to
carry on
that's like after I mean carry on that's
Rock
carry on please unanimous thanks Joe I
know this case the rock wasn't
particularly happy to carry on work
there right thank you
right catch the mill was the question
for Ken's the cargo please
I'm just going back on a question that
Chris catalast earlier about the
closeness of the schools and doctors
facilities I'm just trying it I think
the parish council said 15 miles is that
correct no though the the newest ones
are Biddeford for the health center and
the primary school then you have Oster
which has a health center and three
secondary schools there all are within
about three to four miles Oh three or
four miles so it would be quite
difficult to walk there wouldn't it yeah
yeah but where you can walk there buddy
be difficult okay thanks thanks mark
thank you
just to add on to that the cargo hold
children from secondary school right
from the Grafton's actually get to get
to is there Rus there's a very limited
public transport in this area and the
majority that do go I believe are by car
because as limited transport I think I'm
right in saying that the Warren County
Council are obliged to provide some
probably transport for school children
those of a school age up to a certain
age
okay yep thank you catch the rock please
Thank You chairman I could even count
the cargo up you look you alluded to
sixty mile an hour road and highways
issues but the County camps two highways
officer doesn't seem to have a concern
has he missed something no I don't
believe I am in actual fact in the
supplementary report that was sent to
you the planning officer there is
actually split out what the the the
highway should have responded to the the
one was probably access into the site
but we don't believe and then they can
would be proven proven wrong perhaps but
we don't believe that the other elements
including those elaborate displays and
speeding and suchlike were considered
that's why I've raised it as a concern
and just picking up on that point that
was raised earlier on about the the
safer routes to school that's that
footpath there as part of my delegated
budget that I had that included and
we've heard some of the markings on
because of the issues there and it is a
fast road Thank You Carolyn cash the
kettle please you're muted sir
Chris yeah
okay all right we're now unmuted castor
Cargill the one of the previous speakers
said the there was the health center and
Bigfoot you're saying when they were on
I understand also you happy dog
certainly play the speaker's comments or
conflict on them absolutely she was
correct the nearest one is probably
Biddeford the three miles or so just
over three miles and also between three
and four miles okay
rejecting okay um primary school I
thought the previous speaker said there
was a private school primary school in
the village it's correct
okay so secondary school is in austere
Dahlstrom
and the primary school is actually
temple garden itself yeah I'm not saying
there isn't this there's a secondary
that sorry a primary school in Austria
as well however the nearest one of
course is the village itself thank you
thank you for that
any further questions for the ward
member thank you cares the cargo
thank you very much in G chair thank you
clarification with the officer right any
questions for the officer
catch the kettle and then cast the rock
just settled yeah sorry well this again
I'm just trying to get the young mute
button to work on before you allow me to
speak but that'd be quite a dangerous
thing for you to do we referred earlier
on in the previous application to the
report that cabinet adopted back end of
last year GTAA 2019 which suggests that
gypsy and tremolo sites should be
located a maximum distance of either
four four point eight comes from the
stratford manor or sentence or three
consoles from local service villages
what is the nearest local service
village to this site and is it to within
three kilometers chairman we have the
problem again of questions that we
haven't prepared for and we could very
reasonably have prepared for half the
council the gibbler's warning the
distance to service villages or other
services is very similar to this site as
it is to the houses next door and to the
other gypsy site on Croft Lane it's
remarkably similar put together
questions in advance when I haven't
heard the ward member or the local
villagers comments I don't have a
crystal ball mr. chairman
this is a new introduction I'm having to
write questions at the advance and the
old days when asked officers questions
and they suppose you announcer this is
the new normal I don't think anybody
said that before I'm concerned that
because of the delayed and because we're
not the actual Elizabeth house things
are more difficult to get an immediate
answer for the information is not there
so that's that's why I'm concerned
we do need to get as many questions in
advance if possible to the offices so
they can prepare and because they are
working in trying in difficult
circumstances where they haven't got
access to the normal facilities that
they would so I think that was the point
mr. Barker was rising and I would fully
endorse that and but if we can it would
make sense in if we can preempted as
well it prevents the rise in the meeting
we have enough problems with technical
issues on meeting and things like that
so anything that can make the meeting go
more smoothly I'm more than happy to
endorse so we can put it on the screen
and the council can tell us which
paragraph is thinking of and we can
answer council council this paragraph
two points to three I would add mr.
chairman but this is an application
about Egyptian travel aside and this is
a document this cut the counselor has
produced when the last six months
I just heard thoughts and I have it on
the screen it would be appropriate in
future if there are relevant documents
but between the various schools and
villages such as so again of course
which is why because I have the document
here in front of us now so members can
see it I just you can't see it Hey - pi
- frankly you can't see it you might
need blown up a little bit dial 3.3 yeah
yeah yeah I'm trying to blow it up first
would you like me to share this screen
I've got um might be larger on to what
most of the me Fiona please do it yeah I
try Hank give me a moment
yeah I'll come out
can you see that okay that's paragraph
two point two three thank you and if I
go on to Google Earth which I have done
it's at this site is there's about six
kilometers from Oscar and it's bad for
plus kilometers to Biddeford so the
policy says it needs to be three traumas
from local server to the link
misapplication and fails on that test
yeah chairman I think 2.23 should also
be read in context with two point two
and one which is the intention to
identify sites and of course it is best
to identify a site that's close to these
services and the council hasn't done
that we're having to deal with sites
that are coming forward from the public
and in the absence of a five year supply
as we've discussed before we have to
accept compromises because we need to
provide nation for people so that that
is my answer it doesn't comply with the
aspirations of the council in the GTA
but the council hasn't identified the
sites at the GTA requires it to identify
further chairman it's Fiona further
today was point could I share an extract
from the core strategy policy CS 21 it's
a map that might be useful just
identifying broad locations inside
provision it was raised in the earlier
application the site
which didn't fall within the broad
location identified if I could share
that with you that might be helpful in
the comments yeah
bear with me
one screens flickering on the webpage
page on of my team and purses just
moving a bit quicker than I'd like
okay so this plan here fun enlarged I
hope that's visible so it's map one
gypsy and traveler site provision broad
locations and it identifies main
settlements main rural senators and
you'll see here broad locations for such
provision broad location one is the
purple suede across the site and I
believe the temple graphed and sits
between Biddeford on Aven so it's
probably long that's the main road I
believe here is it the Stratford Road
and the site I thinks it's roughly here
so just in the context of sites and all
policies perfectly useful to point out
that this site does actually lie within
a broad location
right
any further questions for the officer no
yes I've written question I'm sorry
hasn't come through Thank You sheriff
you're the map if you've still got that
document in front of you you keep going
forwards two pages the page sorry to
page down for making which you should
have a keen on other than 20 CS 21 page
1 1 8 the first page of CS 21 right
there we are
paragraph 2 the site is not the KT
within an area of discrimination in
historic or environment reports will not
compromise objectives of any national or
local designation including this special
landscape area does that include
conservation areas and is the Arden is
the Arden the area is this despite
within the Arden special landscape area
yes counselor I can confirm the site
does lie within the orden special
landscape area it's not within a
designated heritage asset conservation
areas are nearby but the site doesn't
fall within the conservation area for
monitoring it is yes if I make sure just
before we leave this policy now I refer
you to the the the first two lines of it
proposals for the provision of permanent
temporary and transient transit gypsy
and traveler pictures and traveling show
people plots will be considered against
the following criteria it doesn't have
to pass all
that's just the list of things you need
to consider in coming to a conclusion
it's not a checklist catch the mills
then catch the rock plays thanks miss
Janet Fiona I'm sorry could could you go
back on to the photograph that shows the
back of the site going on the on the
footpath please I think that's one of
yours it may be that one that's the
footpath to the rear of the sites
there's nothing sure yep still you guys
of course that you start there qualities
it's everything is difficult isn't it
blame the chairman Fiona I would yeah
that's the one yeah that's thanks so
much that's like I mean there's quite a
drop there isn't it from the top of that
field down to where the the site is
going to be and did I understand like
they're going to beat some provisions to
if there is any problem with flooding
then we're going to pop provisions in to
prevent
yeah I get that wrong was I hear things
or read things wrong well they can't put
any provisions in to stop you know
different to get any flooding going on
no we do not mix a response Kevin you
got things okay so the site you're
correct there are differences in the
levels picture on the screen your wide
area the flood risk assessment shows the
levels across a wider area over a 500
meter buffer which
shows change in levels of around 20
meters so sloping towards the east
obviously that's not the difference on
the site within the red line of the
application site
the levels are changeable within just
under a meter so the flood risk
assessment that's been submitted it does
set out recommendations and includes a
sustainable drainage strategy that would
right so yes there are measures that can
be put in place on sites and it
recognized it identifies for example if
it's preferable for flood surface water
flood waters to be completely avoided on
the site that the access road could be
raised slightly and a box culvert
installed underneath to ensure the
access road remains free from flood
waters so that may address that means
Fiona is perfect
although alleges that that may address
the risk on the site flood authority as
I've said in my update won't necessarily
address the risk of flooding elsewhere
I've gotten from my discussions with
them that there are options that can be
put forward for that to be addressed and
because of the small scale of the
developments and the extent of the hard
surfaces are in the roofs of the
caravans and of the utility building the
additional runoff would be relatively
small in comparison perhaps to a bricks
and mortar site so also bearing in mind
it's permeable hard standing in an
access road and in line with our
recently adopted SPD or climate change
we'd be looking at the drainage
hierarchy when we consider any details
pursuant to my suggested condition and
in this case it would probably be an
ideal candidate for rainwater harvesting
of the runoff from the roof so there is
a bathroom proposed in the dayroom
utility room and that water could be
reused grain water harvesting brushing
for example so we all can't
this can be addressed thank you thank
you very much indeed catch the rock
apologies I think I got slightly
confused when guess the kettle we'll
share in the screen and Fiona sharing
the screen and I did miss your question
on the chat so please accept my
apologies and coming two questions first
of all in sequence I think the neighbour
weren't concerned about their right to a
private life I see the human rights act
is not mentioned in the in the material
considerations I imagine that would be a
material consideration if we decide it's
relevant and secondly the ward member
mentioned that the Highways Authority
seemed to not considered other matters
that he was aware of and I'm not quite
sure what that leaves us and these candy
cats or so he probably know but I'm
puzzled by what he said him and what
response we've had he seems to suggest
there's something else that's not in the
report German I think I might be better
person talk instead of both of those
questions than Fiona on the human rights
point the conditions proposed have the
proposed proposed mobile home 10 metres
from the boundary and then from the
boundary to the dwelling is a
considerable distance I'm sorry I don't
have the number in my head but it's well
over 10 metres and of course if it was
conventional housing even if it was two
storey house in which this isn't even if
there was a change in levels we would be
looking for 20 metres between dwellings
so we're extending your normal standard
for bricks and mortar dwellings and
officers can't see any reason to impose
a more stringent standard on caravans
than we do on bricks and mortar
dwellings so in terms of you
rights the human rights of the the
existing residents would be no more
affected than the human rights of
anybody who has a neighbor 20 meters
away on the second point we don't have a
highway officer here to advise us and we
haven't asked the highway officer the
question that was raised and that the
highways officer would normally consider
is the only answer that I can give to
you is that something to that day when I
received the highways response I did go
back to them and asked them if they'd
they were aware of the new access
because I think there's counselors and
the public are definitely aware irie
consulted and we advertised on this
application because the new access
wasn't in the original description so it
went back out to read the advertisement
and consultation and I specifically
asked the Highways Authority if they've
considered the need to condition
visibility splaine's
cetera and they did reply and they said
that since displays shown on the plan
are clear of the hedge most likely Virge
I don't think an additional condition
and regarding splays is necessary hence
I haven't grafted her or suggested her
condition because they are shown on the
plan in any event which we this is a
proof it would be some obviously subject
to being in accordance with the plans
submitted so I did query that with them
and that is the response that catch the
fielding please just just a very quick
question is that the the field is that
permanent pasture Ridge and furrow or
has it been cultivated
I'm sorry I can't really describe
exactly what the psychology is there in
terms of agriculture we consider that
the lawful use it appears to be an
agricultural use and that's at the
Whitehead site obviously the blue line
extends further than the red line but
the whole of that that area we are of
the opinion it appears to be
agricultural in use well if it's
permanent pasture then it should have
planning permission should it not or am
I wrong to change of use yes we are that
the proposal does include it's for the
change of use it's for the use of the
land for the stationing of caravans for
residential purposes for one Gibson okay
John the cattle
I'm slightly sir let me highways
response is not accessible on the
Internet I've tried a number of times
you respect referred to a subsequent
response seems to give me one response
recorded on our planning system which is
dated can't say that sorry it just has
one swing machine so are you saying of a
second response that whatever sees it's
not on the system when I received the
initial response I did go back to my
colleagues at them County and I asked
the question since it can since it is a
new access being proposed
should we condition provision and
maintenance of unobstructed visibility
splays this is an email to them response
back the plates are shown on the plan
revision B and they'll clear of the
hedge most likely within the highway
verge but I don't think an additional
condition will be necessary I've just
checked it doesn't appear to be don't
know while you've been talking I've
web-enabled it so if counsel and if you
can see it Haley it was a web-enabled it
with he's clearly there in advance we
can just have a look at that mr.
chairman have a great conference a nice
three be great
I see that yeah I can explain our nama
clan and are clear of the hedge most
likely within the highway verge so I
don't think an additional condition will
be necessary my question is just below
[Music]
mr. Bowman the county ecologist is
raised no objections to the proposal but
is that before after that email I don't
have that information to hand irie
consulted all the Consul teas that were
consulted at the initial stage and if I
haven't reported in my report
let me just double check there's no
objection on the 28th
I have no further comments from the
college team
right I think I think we'll move on were
2210 we've we've had a good we've had a
good interrogation of the officer
regarding the different questions and I
think we should move on to the bright
who would thanks mr. chairman mr.
Chairman I I've got the report in my
hand here and I marked all the way
through it maybe every seems to be
racket I put in flood risk of greenways
the house you're flooded to me caravan
site or that sort gypsy site it's gonna
be hit before forget to greenways I
cannot see how you can have a that's a
site all on that that looks like a flood
plain to me I'm very much against this
the fact that you want to put provisions
into stop flooding indicates there is a
problem to me so mr. chairman I'm I'm
afraid I'm going to go against the
officers recommendation for Brock I'm
not happy with this application first of
all it's a creek between the two
villages and therefore the identity of
the two villages should remain as they
are
secondly as counselor
Cargill said we don't know who is going
to be living
it's just a very vague application for a
site that could then be sold on within
the community and I think it's wrong
that we should be allowing even though
we've got a lot of policies in line for
gypsy and Caravan sites and developments
we've got one here where we don't know
who's gonna own it
what sort of relationships going to be
and whether they are related to the
people on the way on the other site and
therefore could try and extend that site
which is already a community in place so
I'm against this on a number of policy
people bits of information I've given
you and I propose that we refuse it I
will second councillor Mills right well
slightly confused proposed or second
there but we'll come back for the second
anyway catch the kettle the Rockland
Council Fleming please Thank You mr.
chairman
I would concur with councillor Mills
there is a photograph quite clearly
showing significant flooding around
greenways and having business type that
is immediately adjacent and on the level
of the access into the site and whatever
it may is say about in in reports from
other areas the photograph demonstrating
flooding so as to me it's flooding into
a special landscape area and see s21
subparagraph 2 despite what mr.
Barker says that is a bit you should
reconsider that we should be considering
it seems in a spiritual landscape area
and we discussed this earlier with
Greenbelt but there were extenuating
circumstances earlier on thirdly our own
document could you prove that supported
by cabinet or approved by cabinet not
less well within the last 12 months says
that we should focus these sights on
we've been for something four point
eight kilometres of Stratford or local
service villages or main rural centres
Semih Grafton is not that good it isn't
a main rural center and it isn't a local
service village so it fails on that
couch thorough look at it should be
within a set distance according to that
2019 document of a medical centre
nearest medical center we're told is in
Biddeford and I have looked up on Google
Earth and as the roads no it is not
within your guideline chimeric in the
oculus we don't talk about school again
it seems fail in line with the
guidelines of school in travel of site
and we have a shortage of those sites in
the history cladding so a caravan they
may be less expensive than destroying a
house but it is still a major problem so
I think that in it that in itself I
would support counts the build is a good
enough reason to refuse it we've seen a
picture we've seen growth of a pod area
between the site of this and around we
have a hut that concerns about highways
highways clearly missed this and I'm
trying to repeatedly during this meeting
to download the highways original
response but unfortunately there's a
fault with it however many times I tried
and we didn't have a second high wave
response had the palpable to see that
second highways response they might have
come back with additional comments I'm
concerned about that evidence being
submitted with the stage because
actually the general public have not
seen it and therefore there might have
one he was born during an update they
haven't been able to do it so I'm really
concerned about the how these issues and
counts the car Goliath or the can't
calculate well has raised that as a
significant issue so that's six points
on my list and I think that is more than
enough reasons to refuse this
application mr. chairman end of my real
previous speakers it just seems to me
there's a considerable number of
policies and considerations that are
weighing against this application not
the the difference between this and
other things that elsewhere are very
special circumstances that would weigh
the other way
there aren't any that I can say the only
thing we've got weighing against it is
the lack of housing supply there aren't
any very special service as an
impersonal need and we can identify
because it's a speculative application
therefore I agree with everything else
that said with due consideration
councilor kettle I think we might be
unwise to add highways into the mix I
think there's enough to refuse that on
the basis I am concerned about a highway
side of it but we've had advice in
previous applications that when we've
had technical advice to the contrary
it's difficult for us to go against that
but so I think for all the other things
that would have been mentioned and are
actually listed in the report I think we
should refuse this application Thank You
chairman Thank You councillor Fleming
please and then mr.
- yeah and I think sort of counselor
kettled pinched most of the Thunderer
what I was going to come away with in my
status statement but while we were
looking at CS 21 and everybody was
focusing on paragraph 2 but I couldn't
look at number 4 and it said we
shouldn't really be looking at anywhere
that floods so I think that's sort of
acts of all the things that's already
been said about flooding anyway and I
think on the unsustainability of the
village and and another considerations
like that I mean I I live in Biddeford I
Drive past that site three or four times
a week and I know when there's been
water there seems straight on the top of
a hill there's a flooding issue but
there definitely is one so I won't be it
won't be supporting the officers
recommendation thank you right my sir -
come on please yes thanks yeah it's just
my point last week about highways look
at the weeks before where we had no
technical evidence to go against
highways and I would suggest that the
same issue is here against the local
flood authority as well basically we've
had comments from them and the councils
have seen one picture which may have
been a one-off in a hundred year event
so it's again coming back down to
evidence that this site is a flood issue
supposed to be when we've had technical
issues from the flood agency so I would
be wary about going against that unless
we can actually bring some better
evidence to the table
yeah thank you my sir
Chris I'll bring you in a minute Chris
Moyles yeah I was lot concerned because
there were some conditions it was
mentioned that it could be alleviated by
my conditions so that was my concern
my other concern about this but this
application on the first one today the
extension
kept the kettle mentioned one of my
phrases from a previous counselor if
it's not quite right it's wrong and
there's quite a few things that we've
not got the information that there's
these things I pointed out in the report
that on the basis of this or or the
information was not provided by the
applicant and there seems to be some
gaps in there that I don't particularly
particularly like so to be consistent I
think we need to have all the
information in front of us and I don't
think we particularly have so I'm not
particularly keen on this application
whether that is you know obviously
that's not a strong enough reason for
refusal but I think there's lots of
information missing and not provided by
the applicant we shall find if necessary
so Armand slightly concerned about that
catch the Millstone catch the rock yeah
thanks mr. chairman yes just going back
to what mace has said my goodness me you
say may not happen in 100 years I mean
it's happened that has happened there
you can see it and the way climate
change is going at the moment it's going
to happen again and very very soon so
honestly my my mind flooding is a
problem despite what they say thank you
go to the rock place it's just it's
coming back with name Mason I completely
take the point that he makes about
evidence bit of look at the lead local
flood authority comments it says if the
site cannot infiltrate and requires a
positive ad for such as a water course
or sewer
it isn't clear how this could be done
without increasing the flood risk now
from what I can see they the site
consists of somewhere that has a
catchment as runoff going into it and
reservations have been expressed by the
flood authority here so I think we've
got the evidences in pictures and we've
got a reservation expressed by the blood
or authority so and they're flooding map
has got it's shown as a flood area so
this they're expressing that there may
be a way of doing it but what it is not
clear so there isn't a way forward
there's an absence of information
demonstrating the flood risk can be
satisfactorily ameliorated so I think
there is enough evidence to do it and
but I respect that
Mason Ash's guiding us here thank you
right my cert then cast the kettle
please sure I mean I share the
councillors frustration but to me I mean
yes there is one picture of flooding the
flood even sees comments could have been
better
I'm just worried that the council's are
going to put a reason down if they're
mindful to refuse about flooding when
they don't have evidence to back up what
is happening on that site yes they've
seen a picture the local councillors
gone past there is flooding but we need
some written evidence and I would
suggest what you said councillor Crump
basically maybe sending this back for
for more information because at the
moment it's not clear and even there are
concerns from the election so I said
again there are concerns from the local
flood agency so maybe we need some more
technical details so to alleviate the
councillors concerns yeah so even though
even update sheets that this comments
isn't there about from the legal aid
called flooded and the Fri does not
include a viable drainage strategy with
such included said there's this
different cop sir that's my my concern
and I'm concerned that we're making or
being us to making a decision without
all the information in front of us and I
would like some clarity about the
flooding but it's orage particularly
with my over role as road safety
make sure that's been fully taken into
account because like say I've mentioned
it before if it's not right it's wrong
and and it's just a general feeling
about this my fears might be unfounded
but I would be happy for more technical
information to come back on this one and
I do apologize if it's just have to come
back again
but uh I think we do need more
information on this cancer kettle
hey mr. chairman I mean I think there
enough reasons which of which generally
counselors have raised about concerns
about its not complying with all a
number of different areas of our core
strategies so we following Mason's
advice that we could drop the funding as
a reason for objection but I would have
except that looking at page 41 with
Trina might not have 41 but short of her
report which isn't something she does
identify that the access is through a 1
1831 in 30-year plan identified by the
Environment Agency plunderers planning
max and I think that's right I think the
actual redline area avoid for 1 in the
30 but there's a 100-year event which is
she describes as a medium risk in her
report there is then in the next
paragraph it's tender service or
training in suppose those bar sons or
the main sewer but no strategy and then
if we turn over the page its proposed to
dispose of our waste through public
sewer but solely training have a
breaking objection but they comment
there is no public sewer in the area so
the argument these let's get rid of the
water Priscilla urban train so there
isn't one Oh isn't a known one so I'm
sorry
you know it's an impermeable at the
impermeable areas under increase we've
got one 100-year flood risk identified
on my varmint 82 Matt within a 1 to 30
era risk of flooding identified on the
site and outside of immediate red line
area life so I rest my case on the
funding issue it may serve warrants
evidence we can actually look back at
their original Broderick assessment
which
no doubt I shall be told we can't I
should have raised this issue earlier
but if we look at the plan flood risk
assessment there is a on page 12 that
there is a map that quite clearly shows
significant flooding immediately in the
vicinity of the vicarage and to the
living the match right
getting to the west of the vicarage the
extent that the access to the site has
been drawn to avoid that funded area it
doesn't mean the ground round it won't
be flooded particular food the ground is
imposable and there is no sewer to take
the water away and Troy the husband so
are the active the residents of
greenways would have made good use of it
to get rid of the water previously
just to reiterate I do share the
councillors concerns by just looking at
the details and the report and what's
been shown tonight I do have some issues
about the flooding situation and I think
to give a reason where there are so many
well there's a few gaps in the details I
don't think that would be a good idea
I'd rather the council's actually send
it back for more of a technical updates
because they obviously have concerns
Rock yeah I'm sorry oh that's that was
my my things I've made that clear the
last 10 minutes or so now that I think
we do need more information find that
information for you
did you sorry sir no end of it okay
if it helps sure we're happy to take it
back and find that information for you
okay I'll just see what the other
members of the committee minded to do I
might be majority minority of one so I'm
yeah I might be talking outta my hat it
is people would say count to the rock
general I was going to propose refused
this application for all the reasons
against policy that are stated in here
and then we say the very special
circumstances do not have way those
areas and we apply a note to it that we
are also concerned about that there is
insufficient information to demonstrate
that the flood risk has been
satisfactory dealt with but that
wouldn't be a reason for refusal but it
would be advice to the applicants that
that was something they would need to
address in some other application is
that we don't have to go through the
whole thing again anyway that's my chair
I can't secondary councillor Mills is
proposal saying that I would second it
on the various grounds of that we've
gone through and it's been expanded
everyone else my main query is we don't
know who's the applicant it may just be
somebody who is using this as a ruse to
get a caravan park there or something
we've got to have our information we
can't we can't speculate too much you
know I know I appreciate that
Kent's the mill did mention flooding
initially is part of this proposal and
obviously year a second did not I'm not
happy to go on the grounds of so I
wouldn't support a refusal on the
grounds of flooding
again I might be a minority of one if
we're going to come up with some reasons
to refuse I'm happy to see them happy
them to be made clear and then we can
have a proposal in a second there but we
seem to have gone when the house is
called a bit I'd like to see some clear
proposals I thought so
mr. Chairman I thought to Nigel's
proposal and it was seconded by it by
Peter there but we know but we know the
other proposal from I thought your
proposed building I I didn't propose it
I just said what I thought oh yeah chair
I think council fielding was he assumed
that councillor Mills had made a motion
he was seconding it but obviously that
was a mistake so I think therefore we
need to refer to Council Rock I think
made that proposal
so catch the rock can you come back in
please with a summary of of your
proposal to refuse its application my my
proposes refused the application on the
basis of all the various breaches of our
planning policy that are mentioned in
the report which I can't quite other
pages now and they're not half way by
any very special circumstances chair I
do I think if the rock needs to be more
clear on that please you need to
actually find the policies look further
and then we only apply a note on the
basis of the flooding
mr. Ricardo yes ghost kurtal it's
somebody else can find it quicker in the
report I'm happy with that right the the
issues that I identified am i except I'm
not counselor Mesa miss mister - is
advice the highways does not narrow we
can go and he'd I think that the storm
came flooding is there a concern there
to advisors so that leaves us with a
special landscape area which is CS 21
subparagraph 2 and the Jeep GTA a 20-19
which is a doctor by cabinet last year
I'm hoping this summation that which
says that gypsum travel site should be
located maximum four point eight
kilometres from Stratford and the mayor
or centers outside the Greenbelt
or three comments as the circle service
villages must have both a GP in primary
school and are outside the Greenbelt we
fail that so paragraph 2.23 we fail
under those tests as well so school
Medical Center special landscape area
and I think the parish identified on fat
mister cargo my counselor kaga Maidan
identified had this been an application
for a normal house there would be an
assessment of the impact on listed
buildings with within the area so I
think those are areas which I think we
could use if we're not going to go down
the flooding and highways routes which I
accept from mr. Nash are obviously
supposed to drop 38 proposal completely
objective c 5 CH 9 B - CS 12 C 21 of the
strategy and 117 BNP PA so it's all
written out there which I think actually
I was looking for it while councillor
Kent was speaking so I couldn't do two
things at once but possibly he's just
said the same thing but those things are
great
I agree with Camp Rock can I ask that
stain or gonna take us through those
pending reasons please yes thank you
thank you my sir I was going to say I
was happy and I understood council of
rocks issues that he was Council Rock
who went through the note regarding
flooding the SLA no it's counselor note
regarding clothing SLA the GPA mister
buildings I understood that
I've got a grasp on that I am but the
the issue that was the rocks just come
up with CS 5 CS 9 is 12 steers 21 I
think we need to work through those
because I don't know embers have
actually agreed to all of them so well I
find cs5
cs1 take some time I'm afraid yeah
for the next one
you
so the Sears tribe is landscape so
you're saying impact on the SLA
is your concern and it fails follow
policy 5 as a consequence I can't see
the SLA mention but that doesn't matter
because it is still part of the
landscape yes 9 which is design I think
cs9 is design and distinctiveness yeah
with all members in what way does it not
deliver high quality design or local
distinctiveness it's not our if these
aren't our words whose the offices words
so perhaps the officer could explain if
mr. bark would like why she feel cs9 is
in conflict with this application so I
have cs9 a design and distinctiveness so
this policy specifically speaks about
proposals that would damage or destroy
features which positively contribute to
local distinctiveness will not be
permitted all forms of development
should improve the quality of the public
realm and in Holland sense of place
respecting character and distinctiveness
of locality and then policy cs9 Part B -
specifically mentioned in the report and
whether it's sensitive - it's um its
context so in terms of its layout
sensitivity
setting I think I'd referred in here too
it's the open countryside location and
the existing hedgerow and trees along
the road frontage that unbroken gap
between temporal graft and then Arden's
Grafton so those policies were in that
context of design and distinctiveness
particularly sensitivity building on the
the debates and what was in the report
and I'm sensing that what the officers
lay there is those are the reasons for
refusal I've stated in that paragraph
that the officers just explained to us
so that's my proposal and it's not
outweighed by very special circumstances
working our way through CS 12 builds on
cs5 because that's the the SLA policy
and then CS 21 which part of CS 21 well
in what way you think it conflicts with
CS 21 in fact 2019 closer to services
issue is obviously for my own thank you
GPA is to paragraph three point two
three a G of the GTA a yeah so does that
reappear in CS 21 or do we replace CS 21
with the GTA it's the question I'm
asking the GTA a superseded the core
strategy and therefore that is the most
recent and that was adopted last year by
Canada
so counsel you Saints the s21 is not a
reason for refusal I'm saying in
addition that these are in addition in
traditional lectures that come in GTA a
does not does not counteract see s21
which has been endorsed by the inspector
these are additional features that
Hammond has reported which is
applications fails to me you know so and
what way does it fail to meet see s21
well the site if this location of the
site is within it or is adjacent to an
area designated important scape area
yeah environment security facilities and
be acceptable in terms of foul and so
water drainage perhaps we don't want
that one in in view of Mason ashes
comment so perhaps we leave number ten
hours yes okay I'm comfortable with that
so to recap distinctiveness we've got 21
to with cheese and I've lost again
heritage was certainly English that is
that you know such a reason your refusal
members in fact on heritage assets I
have to say I've strongly recommend
against that very firm reasons refusal
here but I don't think adding heritage
into it will actually help you in any
way well that's not then
all right we just a paragraph ten the
officer does in her report say that
there is no access to main purush and
yet that we understand we do you
therefore forget about the funding there
is a sewerage issue as well and if we
look at ten terminus tears 21 paragraph
ten
it cannot be acceptable in terms of foul
water drainage at squeezing surface
water drainage if there is no adequate
opportunity for disposing of our water
that was where we didn't have the
information I think in the event there
are no servers that can be connected to
provision I'm looking at time I network
is is is not looking good
can you hear me yes paragraph from the
top for a page 41 and then more
importantly paragraph one two three or
of page 42 under the heading for water
drainage on the matter of foul rain
image and the application form does say
they proposed technically made suits and
seven Trent have committees and but we
drafted a condition
and that's sufficient really to address
the proposal the wording on here we've
condition 10 the drainage can be dealt
with by condition so similar to the
surface water management and disposal
the drainage strategy the foul sewage or
drainage would be dealt with in the same
way there's something that could be
mitigated yeah we stoped
there's still absence of information to
confirm where there are sewers or not so
I'm not particularly yeah again I think
we need to know this is this is why when
I was proposing that we deferred it for
more information that was one of the
items I was considering so but I think
you've got enough I think though should
be happy there's enough reasons there
for members to make the decision upon on
the basis that the proposed harm caused
on the various cost strategy numbers
nothing they will read the most in a bit
a ways the special circumstances of the
shortage of gypsy and travelers pitches
in our core strategy lack of five year
hose and run supply starts tomorrow is
that sufficiently yes I'm happy wish
yeah please yeah and obviously I will
want time to draft these tomorrow and
your agreement please do them before we
send them out yes you'll do is but the
the there with the harm caused to the
landscape specifically to the SLA brings
it into conflict with policy cs5 and CS
12 that the
stationing of caravans and the design of
the day room is of Paul design and
doesn't reflect local distinctiveness
which brings into conflict with cs9 and
that although it is a gypsy proposal it
fails see s21 as because it's located in
special landscape area so we roll back
into the first two and that those
reasons together significantly and is
monster ibly outweigh the benefits of
providing a further gypsy pitch on this
site they have to work the back so
because he was proposal second properly
how do we sell look really for somebody
to second this I'm second yeah so we've
had a proposal to refuse the application
based on the reasons mentioned recently
by mr. Barker and they why the very
special circumstances the final wording
will be agreed for this subject
depending on the boat will be agreed by
myself and mr. Barker this week so I
will now go to the rate proposal is to
refuse the application all those in
favor Libya if you could yeah abstain
councillor Mills refused application for
yeah counts the fielding refused the
application that's the Fleming I'll say
for to refuse Thank You councillor
Seraphin for use the application that's
laquetta application i think counselor
rock for refusal of the application
share that 6 4 and 1 abstention right
committee resolves to refuse application
number 20 / 0 0 1 3 9 ful thank you
right there is no urgent business so
declare the meeting closed thank you